[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
je
et salut à tous pour sète cette nouvelle
après midi donc je suis maître
internationale féminine
andréanne havre tesco et je serai
accompagné de gm fabry be pour cette
finale
cette finale delà de la scc féminine
speech challenge féminin cette finale
qui opposera vanina donc bien connue du
grand du grand public à un ami me l'a
donc voilà oui la revanche
on espère la revanche même si
honnêtement je dois t'avouer que aux
chineurs
elle impressionne vraiment j'ai suivi
j'ai suivi au hockey alors je vais
essayer content super mois là ok ok ok
ok j'entends j'entends ce que vous dites
enfin à oui je vais aller dans gouttes
je me dis je vais augmenter le volume
si je peux le problème c'est que lille
est déjà à fond et je sais pas comment
c'est pas comme je fais d'habitude un
ouais mais en fait le problème c'est que
les volumes ils sont déjà à fond en fait
[Musique]
ah non non non je sais je sais je sais
comment j'ai fait attendez attendez
paniquez pas j'aime et monk axe j'arrive
désolé petits bugs comme je suis je suis
tout à fait nouvelle avec ce genre de
technologie j'arrive les gars
et je vais connecter mon taxes
connecte à toi
non je sais je sais pourquoi il tend
dans des étangs tant de mal je sais
pourquoi
en fait c'est mon casque bluetooth il
bug à chaque fois que je l'enlève et que
du coup je dois le désole un légat tout
petit problème technique mais ça va être
réglé en deux secondes
mais le fils c'est un casque bluetooth
c'est le principe de prévoir des fils
d'un petit truc sur la gueule attend
fabi jeu allait me fais pas ça pour
favor non ce casque en fait j'ai
connecté le casque et je pense que ça
c'est idiot au foot il est pas hélas pas
l'air d'activ d'être activée je
cherchais un casque la rive de seconde
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon vous inquiétez pas
j'ai décelé chez au fort taux j'ai un
autre axe trop tôt je suis en forme
ok alors parfois un peu fab merde [ __ ]
[Musique]
ouais mais c'est exactement ce que j'ai
fais tu vois alors et lapins ok là à là
c'est bon ok ça savoir ça c'est réglé
ensuite dit vas y ça c'est bon là tuez
vous entendez là tout le monde vous
entendez fab est ok ouais nickel ok la
pros la prod l'ateq je vous le dis moi
je vous le dit prod matech quoi c'était
bon c'était beau c'était bon c'était
passé voilà c'est moi ok massivement oui
on a tué anna 6 me l'année voilà touche
plus à rien même pas l'échiquier et ben
ça me paraît super bien faut juste que
je le lien cela qu'avec les caméras des
jeux
simple que je n'ai pas reçu donc
donc voilà donc voilà au pire on nous
voit nous c'est le plus est sans doute
important
voilà ça allait jouer j'aime est quand
même allé jusqu'à l'échiquier alors ses
comptes et aux oies c'est pas beau ça
fantastique et clichy qui est un peu
rose violet s'est imposée et du coup qui
aurait pensé par la petite finale partie
entre balla global party et donc katia
et ça à bonson mon jeu comme le risque à
le dire alors sarah cas d'emma charrier
je pense que j'ai bien dit je
rappellerai juste sera personnellement
ça va les leçons de fab là on me disait
que c'était un peu fort que je parlais
plus doucement hockey in espagnol veut
faire des quatre éco avantage - lna ça
joue le centre et tout j'aime j'aime
beaucoup la fête j'ai déjà joué ça quand
j'étais plus jeune mais c'est chaud etc
les mains battre les blancs
ah oui oui puisque avec les north and so
fresh tu veux aux pieds vous route ça a
fléchi kg style je ne sais pas et je
fais ce qu'il sait si ce je crois que
c'est ce que tu vas léger 6 tout ça
mouais c'est pas le problème l'endroit
et c'est choquant qu un pas balade hors
change et d'amour
[Musique]
ça ouais on va déjà jouer pour garder le
droit de verser au centre après je sais
pas quel point c c'est un sacrifice
positionne à la tour qui peut débarquer
à 7
les autres tours au centre la paire
doffou wes un peu changé pour les marges
pansard 1 sur notre direct et et katia
les perdu contre vanina la deuxième elle
avait peur du conte de vanina c'était
assez exceptionnel à suivre aussi parce
que tu es égalité puis à la dernière
partie katia avait une pièce de plus de
plus en plus pas quoi c'était dans la
dernière partie de bullet et et je sais
pas elle a craqué la craqué mentalement
et du coup vanilla l'a emporté le plus
solide mentalement values grâce à son
mental ray ce qui paraît ce qui peut
paraître assez étrange parce que vanina
elle est pas non plus réputé pour être
la solidité même mai
mais là n'était elle était plus forte ok
et du couteau en finale tu penses ou
chenilles la favorite ouais ou china
favorite l'argent pour moi et m'a
vraiment vraiment pour impressionner en
fait j'ai regardé les matches d'avant
bas comme vanina justement l'autre
l'autre finale du premier grand prix
c'était impressionnant avec quelques
secondes à la pointe jules elle a joué
une finale technique mais mais d'une
précision
honnêtement j'ai jamais vu ça élégant
même de 1750 en blitz chose comme chez
nina c'est incroyable mouais on avait
vraiment impressionné alors que sur les
shégués - enfin c'est sûr qu'elle a un
grand talent parce que j'aime bien du
monde mais je ne sais pas en ce moment
je pense qu'il faut il faut pas grand
chose n'est pas heureusement
meiway sur l'échiquier vent fort motivé
quand elle est championne du monde sait
ça c'est clair
c'est ce que c'est ce que je présume
aussi me away incroyable à paris
thiès comme c'était assez impressionnant
bond rappelons que katia l'un peut
patiner la lente agile et plus trop
flagrant ben on va en voir un vent moyen
ça sur mais bon déjà depuis la perte
d'eau chaude questions faciles roy va
devoir alors été tendre à un moment
atteint par ses six têtes
ouais ouais ouais c'est s'asseoir à
17h06 soit peut-être le plus vendu 7 et
puis on attend que ça passe car wyatt
schrassig il est sur les rails et cisco
vrai dire j'ai cinq sais pas si c'est
plus une faiblesse que j'aurais pas pu
se dire que que j'ai raison que nous
venons de gagner en sicile un peu
fragile outre en détours à 6 défaut aux
cinq déchets pas des trucs à droite à
gauche
j'ai tendance à fait correctement oui et
où tu recevoir des vacances pas non plus
si évident est apte à jouer toi ses 6 pi
2 choses à rager j'ai joué une phase
c'était la phase bull est en plus un et
je suis passé de 21 50 à 19 50
dans le même temps le noir donc c'est
pour dire tu as très bien passée d'une
forte oralement est franchement ça va
mais là je perdais des 15 cents
nettement ses intérêts dit que j'étais
vraiment pas enfin du coup j'ai pas
retenter l'expérience
ouais ouais mais il ya toujours des
qualifs la réponse est non on a eu un
coup de canif mairie de calisto ça mais
c'est quoi leur désir de faire quatre
fois le même temps d'en finir
alors je crois que alors je vous mets
tous les jours tous les joueurs nous
sommes voilà hayatou les joueurs est en
fait le principe c'est que chaque joueur
peut jouer trois grands grands prix sur
cinq
à l'exact même chose que sur les grands
prix fidh
voilà il n'en manquait déjà le monde
voilà donc bon j'ai pas insulter ok tu
voir les points suivants où tu vas
c'est ça en général à la fin voilà
exactement classement du grand prix
il n'y a pas de gentils avec moi c'est
juste un classement cia a hier en finale
je crois que c'est le vin juliette comme
ça il me semble je veux bouquet final
ways
non mais c'est cool qu'ils fassent
qu'ils fassent des trucs pour les mères
franchement je suis contente parce que
ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de tournois organisés pour les très
forts très forts beaux jours le d'imams
quoi web à toutes les semaines en plus
donc on sait bien et je joue super bien
et s'est réjoui que ça va recommencer
ils vont faire un tour à des légendes
dont tu dis légende qui tend à part les
gens qui attaquent kasparov fbi annoncé
les mamans c'est toujours pareil mais
ouais c'est ça que je trouve un peu
dommage on aimerait bien un peu plus de
variété sur la chaîne sur mason chicken
quoi surtout que ceux qui jouent même si
on regarde purement l'aspect financier
ce qui joue tout le temps c'est pas ce
que n'ont plus besoin malheureusement
donc bon c'est comme ça mais j'espère ah
ben ouais vous verrez ça reprend je vous
parlais fait pendant que tu as des
projets c'était d'ailleurs la première
jouée je sais pas
[Musique]
vous allez au cap mais du coup ça s'est
pressée après l'été ouais mais ça allait
faire du ballon ça atténue dirais je
voulais enfin on m'a dit tu peux aller à
la coupe d'europe des clubs si ça se
tient
parce que ouais je sais pas si tu as tu
restes un cliché ou pas ne pas parler
j'ai pas prévu de partir tu vois c'est
aussi une offre de ouf de chimie
non je peux rester coi non moi je vais
partir d aix en provence je vais
j'allais à mulhouse
ouais
du coup m'a dit bah si la coupe d'europe
des clubs
tu as une place dans l'équipe chez
marvel se tiennent du gourmet grosses
sommes ce sera j'en ai absolument aucune
idée en europe ouais généralement c'est
toujours des trucs de ouf la coupe
d'europe des clubs donc bon j'en rigole
oui il ya de grandes chances que ce soit
en grèce
mais ok bien voilà mais sinon on a un
choix qu'il ya un petit on est en
belgique on va les faire à bruges fin
août
c'est l'un des c'est l'un des seuls qui
tient en europe juge lui que ce joueur
on servir souvent mouais
les fauteuils des dominique chambon
comme au tennis ou parapubliques
séquençage et je crois qu'il rate warren
sapp les pieds de la station finale eh
ben il se trouve que cas si elle va pas
réussir un peu cafouillé well on discute
bon temps soit savoir partie faut
laisser chauffer il ya dix mois de juste
le 2 août il y aura les trois cadence et
yahoo
alors le truc c'est que un seul le
stream en anglais à l'hôtel maire de
gagner des portions
parce qu'en fait ils n'arrivent pas à
faire un truc qui soit uniforme à tout
l'est
non c'est juste le thème mais il
désirait pas à le mettre sur tous les
stream en même temps donc ils n'ont mis
que sur le stream le streaming ne pourra
voir les l'étang des différentes
portions faut aller voir sur eux mais en
gros c'est comme la pta une portion cinq
minutes version 3 minuad a déjà trois
plus un rien plus un jeu mais laissez le
stream anglais pour dire le teint est
sûrement tel comme ça je pourrais vous
dire le temps en même temps ce que
beaucoup de temps dans la même phrase à
et ça y est c'est gagnant en tout cas
c'est georges à monter mais ça laisse à
ses belles et le roi disparu je vais te
l'a appelée plus comment ça c'est
qu'elle n'a pas être différent du sillon
bateau que je pense que j'ai contrôle
aldama je sais pas mais moi je sais oui
je serai un lien f5
mais armand web sur moi tu tiens un truc
après tout qu'est le sida ias roi des
cartes mais je crois que tu sais juste
qu'ils c6 peut-être gt1 garde de tenir
tout avec le cadre est elle a voulu
jouer sur le fond mais pas au bout de
nos surprises mais c'est sûr qu'un flou
ça s'est toujours bien calé dans ce
genre de situation mais pas pour
l'arrêter
bonne chance à un dommage elle avait
rêvé bien été bienvenu serein ouais
ouais ouais les décisions bab le fou
dans les positions comme ça en fait
c'est un bien meuble où le cavalier
parce que depuis g7 par exemple ils
aident à faire ashfield dames et défend
b2c 2 les cases des purs noir donc voilà
donc la xj6 ce qu'il ya faire attaquer
et puis voilà quoi nous manquer a promis
grand prix va s'arrêter ou chez nina et
donc sera fidèle juste après alors
d'entre eux regarder le match de ces
finales
oui alors il ya juste minifone de
cadrage à wichita pas le cas pour avoir
parti mais je peux pourquoi ap c'est
peut-être un deuxième chèque sous verre
ou peut-être que toi moi pour faire main
et ça cela devient xl s'est fait tout
seul sorte sortent des stands yens pour
katia tâter plus pour katia si ouais bon
fichier coutu à mes rêves puisque voice
un patronyme et katia je le connais un
peu de gibraltar et manger français avec
vlad ça je vois je vois non moi chez
welch et enfin j'ai l'impression que
katia est très très sympa effectivement
mais j'ai passé plus pour la jeunesse
moi donc j'ai un vieux sur la vieillesse
ou de mari compréhensif te plaît il
reste 17 minutes dans la partie en
simple et sain ok donc genre trois
parties sur m pour le prenne j'aime
passer en caisse fait c'est un peu
[Musique]
avec lui dans la prépa tu ferais quoi la
c5 v6 ou du john deere
non moi je suis plus en plus du genre à
faire des cinq cas pas de suite je ne
sais pas mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
faut graisser fois grâce et les blancs
oui oui même s'il faut croire que les
preuves de ouais ça a l'air bien sage
3,3 j'imagine fait froid est là comment
on agresse les blancs
ces six tours tout partout ça je suis ok
il ya cinq ans et je joue comme moi
c'était pas si t'es pas une bonne
nouvelle pour elle mais en tout cas et
dans est dans l'esprit alors voit quoi
les blancs faut déjà des trucs à éviter
d'être un bouc homme qui avait cinq
temps et de faire faire gaffe aux cayes
bref deux à la france 0 4
bon alors alors j'appelle tous les
mécaniciens chez pas exactement pourquoi
merci un coin de la tête non non on peut
pas suivre jusqu'aux halles alors quoi
ça me paraît quand même beaucoup moins 2
c'est rue prises prévient qu'elle
reprend de son emprise psychologique est
un truc comme ça
ok kg 5 milliards 2,4 je pense que ça
serait l'un des saints
épreuve 2 bat west et regarder son
hockey du coup moi j'en passe elle a
ramené son cas il ya cinq ans je ok on
me la faire à 5 j'imagine etc et ses 5
encaissé 5 direct d'ailleurs sans le
faire à 5,6 bon à l'aller les blues
thorn temps de stabiliser un peu la
positive impression ouais ben brik avec
elle trois d'un coup sans devoir partir
d'où il vient
mais problème le roi blanc n'ont fait
quoi mais après les noirs tu peux
toujours jouer genre 3 cette fois je 6
et prendre quatre mètres un truc qu'on
g4 d'ailleurs les parts pour sa passion
points d'écart à louis régis obadia bâle
5 faisait 5 ou quoi pour ce thème qu'est
ce que cous des trois mais je sais que
je peux mettre non plus on a envie de
s'amuser cette case de 4 comme je pense
les neuf accusés change tout cas voilà
ça va les blancs sont hors de danger
bon c'est vrai je continue à bien mais
les noirs mais c'est sûr que par rapport
auquel il rêve de tout à l'heure à quel
point que sa valeur est très très faim
c'est un port pata foin avoir des
petites idées avec lg 5 pièces ont
changé les fous on trouve aussi ce tout
ça ouais alors des tours à 3 le sco
filet mais midi jusqu'à talent et
chauffe espion
ouais ouais c'est pas moi j'aime bien
élevés les bleus allez les blancs pour
sarah donc oui quelle vie aux fraises
allez les blancs
ok marché peut agir à jouer sur le pion
b3 mais bon la tâche et six en l'air
donc moi qu'elle défend comme ça ce qui
est pas mal ce qui est pas mal
satisfaite colonna réfugié 5 sais pas je
pense que le fils et le pion mais c'est
pas le cas elles vont perdre 1 h 3
sûrement un jour
ouais j'ai 5
mais tata faire des médecins quand tu
changes qui on prend quand même tomber
vite tomber deux effectives et ouais je
pense se faire un truc comme ça sur je
crois que votre combat n'est pas un peu
parce que c'est notre cas le défendre
est ce qu'on prend le pion j-6
probablement je pense c'est super chaud
ok alors on fait quoi
ce tueur en même temps cagliari 4-1
cadets achète c'est bien joué à trouver
des très bons coups défensifs katia les
vieux l'expérience tout ça pendulo sa
valise ans domine plus ou moins mais je
sais pas trop passer très très chaud
comme position en fait écrit mme
lantagne
eh bien je suis dj que j'estime
j'attaque h3g pas trop de problèmes mais
vu que t'es tour contre aurait avec les
blancs et les noirs la torah de l'autour
spinning 18 ans il ya déjà quelques
parties sont les futures attaques f3
c'est pas tout on sale mais alors
réfléchi nantes 1 pour faire d'un congé
6 je pense qu'elles combinent pour
provoquer projet s'inquiète 1.3 s'avère
quand même très chaud vous faites plus
régler north a pas trop été requis
étrangers cinq mois la fête chez basse
se trouve qu'avec le fou pas bon
compléter les lits et laquelle j'ai
quelques soucis game c'est gagnant
qu'elle est jeune belge et que tu
menaces cavaliers partout la jeunesse
tout bon vieux truc et leucate c'est pas
mal mais kg 4 saveurs plus du pij fut
peut-être ouais ce qu'était cette
manière sans âge c'est sûrement je ne
sais pas j'en fais kg 4 deux options
le danemark est maintenant peut-être
même des chais pas la nef set ça se
trouve ça défend à peu près
même ça tu sais pas si ça n'avait aucun
sens capable de mettre sa tête mais ça
c'était ça le truc c'est que des mecs
n'était pas possible d'accord ce qui est
ça la grosse boîte 8 je pense c'est nul
mais la fête du fitr aujourd'hui le fou
mais c'est dommage d'arriver cette
opportunité de calage et quintin bon
écoute soir la finale face à dire
qu'elle à l'oeuf pourri mais la torah de
très fortes
j'y crois pour les marins
malheureusement quand je pense à va
faire nul me je crois pas la victoire
des blues mais bon après tout paraît
vrai zombie de son sait pas tout est ok
j'ai senti ce qu'on fait
ok j'ai 100 web du coup la russie
favorite dans ce match je pense que si
les papillons l'américaine 6 mais bon
chang'e 2 fawcett ou un truc comme ça ça
a pas l'air super solide j'ai 4 bat
angers de fouet 7
ouais ouais ok pas mal aussi faux htc
l'onera fillatre à se faire appeler là
j'aime pas ça j'aime passagers 4 à 5
fois plus cher
maintenant que ben oui arrive pourquoi
ça fait quoi au barème n'a pas de tour
de hook up serein et surtout autre chose
de fou 3 qui est roi et c'est là près du
bugue
je fais tout référée jetons ferro g7
machin web on voit ça ça même pas faire
un nul a malheureusement on est en plein
week-end on est en paix slrb les
locataires ouais c'est clair savoir
jouer la même fosse et 5 ou pas sauf que
tu parles
ouais ouais faut qu'elles améliorent un
truc pascal merci davance était partie
d'avant et le roi était en perd et c'est
mais auquel a participé cinq fois
vainqueur ce justement c'est notre ligne
en fait due
[Musique]
mais elle connaît bien avec vous tous
ces trucs est du travail est une blague
ouais ouais puissances ont consacré
toute ton mari dit que peut-être il
demandé ouais elle avoue fait déjà 2 0
pour katia je vois malheureusement juin
juin - sarah revenir ouais c'est cette
portion sera dur après bon ça pas mal
jean durand se sont vu que et reste
comme il reste six minutes à la portion
5 + 1 hockey d'aujourd'hui à dernière
normal une partie se finit en cinq
minutes quand il ya elle peut durer 10
minutes
ouais d'accord ouais donc ouais on verra
bah disons faudrait pas perdre pour
sarah pour déjà moralement tueur attaque
bien le match d'après de plus alors
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavaillé
pointe 4 je me posais des questions
pendant d'autres choses en mains de chat
bah ouais c'est pas c'est pas super
compliqué normalement non commence à
avoir ses flux haddock et le chrétien
food est simple c'est ça sa tête les
deux cavaliers qui serait sur les
hurricanes blanche
du coup c'est un moyen sam au lieu de
défendre alors des fois les noirs et 12
km ce fatras de le faire quand tu fais
le con d'états d'âme et 8 qui défend les
deux
ayrault et chromatique tu espagnol avec
la main si jamais ce jeune espagnol je
crois que je ferais plus les fossettes
classique de vente figurines tout ça sur
un truc de vieux mais faisait 5 6 et
aime bien la mode et c'est bien aussi en
mettre quelques là là le but a créé main
c'est quoi c'est d'atteindre je crois
qu'elle a bien vite aux quinze jours
pour fêter des cinq du coût qui attire
espère faire ok je sais pas c 4 ça m'a
l'air un peu étonnant mais vu qu'elle
veut si vite c'est que vous êtes plus ou
moins normal c'est impatience elle
libère un peu les noirs ouais j'aurais
attendu mais peut-être que f5 ça
l'embêtait réagir ça ok donc ces cas là
je sais pas pourquoi pas prendre les
prend et peut-être un jour faire ces
huit sont il a plus rien à faire en
bessatsu il est venu au début quand
quand c'était il attaqué aux cadres des
trucs maintenant toutes été prises et 5
auquel fait tout s'est vite que je
trouve plus ou moins normal aussi
on va voir qu'on les blancs se placer ce
que l' envie de faire quand même du tour
à 7
comment la partie d'avant fait recours
ce même thème quoi d'autre bah moi faire
un dessin que j'ai posé un moment donné
est-ce que ce cavalier du chien ni bon
coach aura cinq niveaux tout voiture ok
juste f5 alors en touche à rien f5
n'attends rien
j'ai encore des kills pour cinq des six
vols à la technique mans l est pas
1 il est pas à son top ça normalement
ils voient plus de trucs que j'aime tant
elle a loupé pas mal de portes unités
pour mon cas j'ai kadhafi d'avancer
domaine et la web assure puis on prend
un verre des six échecs on n'a pas fou
aussi ce qui semble avec cool parce que
vous contre attaque créé adam la fio
penser cet antre qu'on s'attaque là
d'amateurs est alors ouais c'est un peu
chiant il faut ouvrir la position
peut-être de perdre actions avec les
nerfs de coller l'oreille foyer atteint
1,22 g f 5 bien sûr tintin
ça peut paraître un peu mais j'ai froid
qu'elle a eu peur aussi le souhaitent
les blancs je pense que cette dame b4y
si on menace on fire accueilli 18 je
dire mais il ya quelques mois il ya six
noms sur dans les quatre dom trompions
ah oui non j'ai peur j'ai pensé ouais je
pensais que tu avais la récompense avec
15,5 mais non j'ai rien dit des fois
c'est abusé ouais donc là n'ont du coup
l assemblée et transition c'est pas si
rapide est ok bon tournoi et du polonia
pions 5 ou pas bon c'est bien qu'elle
perd pas franchement moi katia et
quelques super bien sur ce match j'ai
impression on est très très vague et
elle a dû faire l'échauffement avant ni
chaque elle le fait en vrai toute façon
fait des petits exercices le matin de
tactique tout ça pour être en forme et
auxquels je suis sûr c'est le prend le
match au sérieux elle le fait aussi
c'est sa routine un peu de metz ça a du
sens en fait parce qu'on était sportif
aux malfaiteurs tu fais un développement
voisine claire machin bon nous et check
up puisque eu l'air ces régions en faire
un roc en fait de faire ça c'est bien
c'est cher je faisais à l'époque quand
j'étais encore motivé qu'il y avait
encore des tournois en live la venue du
boss un peu ouais ouais j'ai voyagé
trois heures de cours avec un gm là par
semaine mais c'est quand même un certain
investissement
et oui je me dis tu peux pas dire qu'ils
sont non je veux pas dire non mais les
payet pas français c'est pas les indices
avaient déjà les bas-fonds cette nuit
face à jimmy non non je ne dis pas parce
que je sais pas s'il veut que je dise et
puis bon et au pire je dis pas quoi bon
voilà c'est pas non plus super super
important je suppose
juste au fait merci a dit qu manny acta
qui a lancé un raid a dit que monique
super merci ben justement été jetés
j'étais sur son string ce matin ce matin
même
donc c'est moi qui l'ait kylie kylie
ramener na waie du coup bah merci pour
leur aide
ouais merci au grand raid merci ok donc
tu bosses mais quelqu'un de secret ben
ouais ouais ouais c'est bien tu sens que
tu as well well done bah disons que le
fait de payer pour voir des courses et
que je me sens obligé de faire quelque
chose à côté aussi vu que du coup j'ai
pas envie de
de me dire ouais je paie pour rien donc
la salle de muscu j'ai aussi un
abonnement en salle de muscu mais mes
débuts j'ai géré des ménages et dont
j'ai pu de salle de muscu donc la lune a
toujours fermé trop de monsieur moi je
vais vous faire du kart quand tu as
acheté pas j'étais pas trop gros muscu
mai mais bon ça fait quelques mois que
baillargues ok c'est pas parce qu'une
minute danse à la pendule sait jamais si
simple de convertir un tour de plus
question ça coûte combien
combien ça va coûter combien des cours
avec des jeunes ça dépend du grand
maître ça dépend du grand maître ça
dépend où le grand maître vie la réponse
c'est ça dépend oui je dirais qu'elle a
prise normale entre guillemets c'est 50
euros par heure et avant d'après ça doit
être un faux on en rêve voilà un bon tu
vis aussi de bas depuis combien de temps
tu fais ça dans ce cas le truc
oui par exemple gourévitch c'est pas le
même calibre a et b g et ses vacances à
toute leur vie terna ça peut être la
centaine par heure ça dépend doit
suivant si tu vis plein centre de paris
vous ou je sais pas où j'en ai même main
en dehors de france c'est mario la
fiscalité au super mm150 et enfin
minutes blade marmelade sais même pas si
cher à l'achat qu'un soin base
d'investissements mais comme tout est
sombre comme pour tout mais ça je pense
abordable qu'un petit effort
donc conclusion toujours ça dépend ou
alors prenait freiner ddm kempen dans
les pays d'europe de l'ouest
il faut comprendre la langue fait m
non mais ça n'a pas été le concurrent
s'il peut être mondiale ou quoi mais
disons en tant que français à partir du
moment où j'ai dû fait bien les trucs
que tu as leur statut déclaré que tu te
prends l'air ça t'es pas sur un pied
d'égalité barbares quelqu'un qui fait
aux blagues de pipe
c'est juste sa sombre que ce que vous
encourager en europe dans un club
d'échecs alors je pense qu'en ce moment
c'est un peu compliqué des
gestes-barrières infectés mais en
général
moi ce que je dis toujours sur mes
stream c'est que ça ira beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite
si tu prends un coach donc pas forcément
dans un club d'échecs mais en tout cas
faut avoir quelqu'un pour porter juillet
dans la bonne direction je dirais ça va
aller beaucoup plus vite
ouais c'est vrai que ça fait bien cette
idée
ouais juste pour donner des conseils et
par ce qui compte c'est quand même bien
bossé tout ça le coach y va il va te
battais et restauration
mais c'est pas une heure avec un coach
qui sait que là ça c'est pas ça qui va
te faire passer d
le dessin des mines ça c'est sûr le
travail de perso c'est important l
affaire trucs bizarres s'arrache pas là
tu as fait qui est profond enfin tout à
l'heure ouais j'ai vu ça je sais pas
pourquoi
bon c'est aujourd'hui la fête mais la
vie quoi c'est le tour 3 puis on compte
autour de soi même
moralement ça va non mais c'est notre
truc assez important c'est de cette
bosser avec enfin pas de bosser mais de
faire des parties avec un ami et de
jouer les ouvertures et après je regarde
ce que tu as joué tu analyses avec laure
10 heures sup est un moyen super ludique
de bosser les ouvertures s'excite à un
copain avec toi qui après ton de tout
mon niveau
vous jouez les parties dans l'ouverture
que vous venez d'apprendre
vous mettez un fils voulait rentrer dans
l'ordi et puis l'ordi peux vous dire bon
bah voilà la lata maire d'eilat a bien
joué mais en fait le plus important
avant d'être lardy s'est d'abord
d'infléchir soi-même sur la position
bien sûr ça sera beaucoup plus de sens
si tu mets direct leur dis vous tu leur
dis va te donner
réponse mon prêt badoit faut comprendre
vous faire des concepts juste avec des
phrases déjà parce qu'en fait le bruit
de l'eau redescend c'est que c'est des
coups ils sont juste en fait mais si ça
n'a pas de sens ça résonne pas aux
oreilles à se dire ça faut faire sa
propre reine des fêtes
ouais c'est le cavaliere moi j'aime bien
les égyptiens mais bon je savais que mes
trucs de vieux non mais les livres c'est
super bien
du coup fin de la foire session est donc
trois hommes kathia bâ c'est dur c'est
dur parce que j'ai l'impression que
ouais
généralement elle n'est pas super dans
l'ouverture puis après milieu de gel
arrive à revenir elles arrivent à
égalité pour les pros ça ça replonge
quoi c'est difficile ouais si leurs
procédés des stages été conclu je suis
complètement j'étais complet mais j'ai
bien regardé justement donc il ya quand
même une place encore dans le premier le
deuxième jour 3 4 places qui restent
c'est la camsa la can au soleil sur
quatre jours jeudi au dimanche volant
wii non mais pareil fois le stage c'est
comme les courses a pas tout faire un
peu cabossée à côté pour apprendre des
trucs rencontrer du monde c'est un petit
groupe de travail correctement sur notre
curi disques ont une place prioritaire
préfère pas trop être au contact mois
si on peut éviter je préfère éviter quoi
voir venir avec un scaphandre et tout
s'est compliqué parce que j'ai
obama est un tournant aux pays bas elle
accepter la folie totale
parce qu'il m'était deux expliqué pierre
soit way et les mecs ils s'étaient pas
du temps contacté était à un mètre
l'inde est alors qu'il était censé jouer
la même pratique qua non ça c'était la
folie totale corps non mais en fait mais
moi de façon je mangeais pas reprendre
des conditions comme ça tout mais tu
auras sur internet
bon ok c'est mieux que rien mais je sais
pas j'avais pas à sentir de moi je
propose jusqu'à nouvel ordre et puis on
verra combien d'appareils
du coup on se réoriente la pac de stream
avec les stream franchement franchement
c'est super bien c'est cool que cette
place que ouais bon ça fait longtemps
que enfin j'étais songez pas de chaque
perso mais que je n'attends rien fait
avec quelle dont j'aime bien et puis
j'ai aussi entendu déjà des cours et de
l'éclairement parce que je principal a
déjà commencé depuis quelques années oui
bah t'as tes dents longues et moi ça
fait ça fait très longtemps
c'est clair moi je suis nouvelle dans ce
petit milieu et franchement ça me plaît
bien
donc je vais vous allez me voir à votre
grand désarroi vous allez me voir
beaucoup et tu fais tous les jours du
coup way j'étais jeune je fais tous les
jours voilà j'ai pas trop ce crime et
parce que je me préservais je préserve
pour le match de hockey ouais mais il se
passe quoi ah oui petite pause mais oui
exact fraîcheur petite pause fraîcheur
salut à ma greffe au l'oeil qui est la
bourbre écoute qui pâtit quoi ouais
ouais bon coin 30 sont petite finale
c'est juste tout lourd s'échauffer pas
de grosse hype mais la finale va être
intéressant voire c'est aussi chine à ce
qu'elle vous ça c'est ça se passe pas
trop bien pour sarah malheureusement
mais petit à petit favori sur ce match
mais ça se passe pas trop bien
aujourd'hui que non c'est une chance de
marquer un point voire cromois un point
mais bart n'est pas encore fini 3 0 but
que la cadence d'un sexy là ils vont
jouer encore elles vont jouer encore pas
mal de parties mais surtout moralement
ça peut-être pas quoi non c'est clair
pression tu dis ben on va quand même
marqué un point quoi cet ordre est
inverse
cette enquête a qu'a t elle vraiment en
confiance à peu lâché ses coups on
commence ça doit être en matière à un
arrière c'était c'était un très très
long match j'ai gagné dix nuits de fait
demi donc extrêmement serré au buzzer et
en plus et en plus ça pouvait tomber
autant en dernière partie était mal
le flag est sale quoi est ce titre plus
de femmes avant le faire pourtant vu
entreprises de mai
g j'ai demandé aux jo de la chatte
d'intervenir et tendu et donc voilà
ouais c'était extrêmement long terme hd
de quasiment 4 heures c'était c'était un
peu long de phare c'est très présent
heureusement qu'on ne l'avait pas qu'on
l'avait pas streamé chacune d'un côté
parce que franchement je pense que
j'aurais été j'aurais été carbo j'aurai
toujours été un train de dormir nation
mais les cafés ça marche plus genre si
tu en prends tout le temps le problème
c'est que non vraiment ça plus d'effets
il faut passer à autre chose de très
fort mais j'ai peur j'ai pas de pousser
à sa bouche voici il faut il faut un vol
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas pour le
stream travaux pour la communauté à red
bull c'est non je fais un truc récemment
c'est que j'ai arrêté le sucre donc
c'est pas si mal en fait j'essaie de
réduire aussi tout ce qui est carbo
carbo
or blanc non carbo carbo heydrich comme
on distingue lui c'est tout ce qui
glisse ce qui que ce soit ouais c'est ça
j'essaie de réduire jeudi les bienfaits
des produits voilà ça et en plus si vous
êtes aryenne donc c'est compliqué à
trouver à bouffer en ce moment mes
valeurs et du tofu éditeurs ou non en
vrai en vrai ils font des trucs ils font
des trucs à en croire maintenant il ya
la marque américaine dhabi un mythe
s'appelle ses imitations viande mais
c'est incroyable
jean 120 pas du tout du tout du tout
content
ouais c'est le regard ça je sais plus
bas jamais vu le package jamais il ya
les anglais qui font pas le truc pas mal
mais on n'a pas ça en france mais ces
jarres une chaîne de et encore de paix
l'échiquier ma chaîne de magasins
imposible burger exactement il ya passé
ça alors ça repart pour les citadines
g34 alors fait qu'il sait si ce sont
deux coups décisifs à lui refaire au
swing direct du coup je suis sûr que ça
aurait elle répète tout le temps et les
ouvertures
quand ça se passe mal normalement en
fait tu changes tu dis oui et je vais
changer un truc mais sans refaire h 4 h
théâtre et tout ce qui change de m parce
qu'elle n'a pas de raison de changer
après avec que l avenir mais pourtant
échanges et apple sont caillage c'est un
peu de notre l'option mais non je crois
que ça va m'aider mais rien si tu as
trop d'additifs
c'est ça qui me l'a dit qu avant s'est
passé comment voyez-vous une prison à
catane et ouais vous changer un peu il y
avait eu à tous les étages 5 h 4 matches
3 et du coup elle est la chose la vie
elle l'a pas fait mais elle va tout
ouvrira la danse du p5 est sur tous les
fronts craquer là j'aime bien jouer
extrêmement agressif katia dans ce match
en tout cas je trouve qu'elle joue
vraiment bien
mes aïeux qui te dit je propose lait les
viandes ça s'est joué
bah c'est la même marque elle est bien
john wayne au petit déj le petit déj
pourquoi je prends une tranche de pain
avec du beurre saucisse mais là ça
devient un peu chiant ça devient
fleischer il faut plus de seube et du
coup garder ce serait franchement et ça
va ma chaîne je vais acheter l'un de ses
objectifs et ils savent je déjeune moi
qui ai mis mes mains de vior objectif
payer mes classes avec f1 payer mes
cours avec coeur j'aime n'empêche des
objectifs 6 v/m combien hockey du coup
j'aime pas ce qu'a fait savoir
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ait fait
pas trop attendre et quand il s'agit
juste d'atteindre
malheureusement j'ai l'impression
qu'elle fait chaud et une petite
concession par ci une petite concession
par là mais au final katia et c'est bien
pour un avantage de ça et c'est je vois
bien quoi ouais ouais tu sais pas trop
ce que tu veux faire avec les blancs bon
d'ailleurs il a pris une décision c'est
qu'elle a pris à la prime est à deux
cases noires et c'est toujours tendu
c'est clairement un mois 4,4 je me
pointe et 4 le fou g7 prend des cases
préfère qu'il y ait des trois tu le fais
plus qui lâche 5,9 pour moi c'est
difficile
et ouais talent fou qui en 5 ou en d4 un
jour tu as tu fait à 5 tours tout est
trop grave pour un art mais je vois
québec et des bons coups pour les noirs
en fait un problème comme dans une
position elle travaille pas vraiment un
budget pour un côté généralement ces
questions revient pas sur sa fille la
5ème avec les blancs se gagnera toi même
tu as dame tu t'accroches un peu au
moins tu joues pour un truc on n'avait
pas au début mais bon
mathis ont joué est indienne ses nus
natures que lors de ma visite pourrait
dire que je peux jamais jamais pour les
blancs dans leur position c'est une
grande histoire d'amour
voilà je pense que les bouffées à cinq a
pas de raison peut-être obtenir de jeu
n'ont pas abordé la question sarel et
les collègues de 24,50 24,81 mêmes têtes
ouais à côté je vais regarder quand même
gagner des points
voilà sa fille comme j'ai quand même
quelques chaises comme ils ont fait ils
ont filmé foot en écrivant son nom tu
vois 24 94 kw à 94 stratosphérique et
non moi j'ai 200 points de moins j'ai 22
84 donc oui non non tu alors bon du coup
avec les blancs tâter chance parce c'est
toujours pas fun mais maintenant avoir
la même
ah mais bon c'est la loi tepa ouf comme
décision de la part des maires
d'échangés ouais je pense tu vois que
maintenant la pression accrue des blancs
qui bougeait pas moi je suis d'accord un
teint t elle avait le teint de manoeuvre
un peu là du coup à le faire tu cette
dame assad avait cinq dames aux cadres
des trucs s'engouffrer un peu mais ouais
tout peut tout peut arriver à d'autres
donc tu t'étais autour des 8 la main ces
chiens temps limite je passe à valoir
mais si elle le voit c'est fort parce
que le problème c'est que le foie pas
trop de casse des dames des six
attendait 8 super mais je pense qu'elle
va faire tout gagné cette partie du coût
olalala jing sais pas or ce la poisse
pas eva est énorme mais c'est son tour a
eu 8 qui paraît naturel médiateur sens
je pense à toi notre le tournant de la
partie
ouais mais même mais enfin même la juste
avant voilà je suis sérieux ouais enfin
c'est pas facile de rien faire non plus
[Musique]
oui c'est un peu précipité quoi donc la
fille la pièce elle est foutue mais
encore une boule au nom waouh l'ordi qui
changea c'est sûr je suis prêt à
m'engager tpr est en tête sur prêts à
s'engager là c'était la vie et les pions
mais pourquoi ceux qui sont sous contrat
et c'était pas grave tu es là à la
famille quéveau flins bon du coup sa
réelle
bah je voudrais lel ce beauf des six qui
s'inscrit au système et avait dit la
poisse pas vraiment bon c'est pas là tu
vas te faire flinguer les moyens
d'abaisser 2 qui facturent le truc mais
c'était possible de construire une sorte
de forteresse tu as quand même tu mets
une tour en f4 je crois que cela les
tours deux tours est de 3,4 c'est ce qui
est fait je pense que bonne chance au
regard de pas se prendre les dames h1 et
tout ça mais sinon devrait aller et en
même temps qu attirer tout intérêt de
faire durer cette partie qui joue autant
tranquille tu fais dur est à faire
zain un compte sur l'aide de peintures
fresques voilà sur le fair play de katia
j'allais dire ok hager médecin découvre
d'espagnol et encore ces cinq pareil
ouais donc ça te la même que la deuxième
balle au pied mais quand on va voir un
irak ou trois tous à laroque tesson faut
faire tomber cet âge perlim bien son
bout d'chou 17
c'est dans l'intérêt des banques faire
des coups comme des cinq étapes souvent
de fouilles en b sat est content de le
faire tu le bloc mais après c'est bon
cela enlève le cavalier de france et 6
donc amber ni je pense que katia elle
pouvait pas éviter les puisque c'était
une part de presse mais par contre elle
avait intérêt à ce que la partie dure le
plus longtemps possible puisque bas ça
joue autant forcément donc moins que
partie vous qu'il advint sait jauger que
quel est intérêt à faire durer faire
durer la partie quoi ouais c'est pas des
matchs en nombre de partis opposés c'est
en un an de temps en fait donc c'est
peut-être minutes qu'à 20 minutes en
trois minutes pas chez page des chiffres
au hasard donc hanter dro score en fait
plutôt partie elle dure longtemps plus
de 150 coup tu es moins deux parties à
jouer ensuite
mais pour le coup la position c'était
nul juste parce qu'en fait la tour était
protégé par le pion et le bloquer le roi
adverse que tu arrivais goitia que la
dame quoi attaquer un peu le droit à
faire des échecs combat le roi bougeries
cherche toujours à chaque et pas faire
grand chose de plus dans tous les cas la
vague pouvait pas passer donc le seul
capillon tu peux casser leur position
car si tu peux faire un big bang donc tu
force les blanches
bison pas envie de faire mais je crois
pas que de tels scénarios possibles dans
cette opposition ce qu'il y avait des
coups d'attentats tour pourrait reculer
à revenir
donc au final voilà banuls normal dix
communes et pour répondre à ta question
oui il ya beaucoup d'iraniens qui sont
bas les échecs trois échecs
le meilleur d'entre eux en ce moment ses
alliés raisin à quoi sert un wayne brady
s'est énormément de 1700 et hier
astronomie c'est fait voilà un homme en
fait ils ont une politique de formation
a fait venir pas en obligeant sokolov là
bas qui est très bien car il ya
apparemment aussi qui était champion du
monde juniors ils ont tabata qui vont
pour le coup c'est le moins fort des
trois bléquin 2650 ils ont pas mal en
fait et bah le truc ça c'est permanent
mais c'est une politique de formation
qui à force sur sur une dizaine d'années
batata les fruits qui c'est
l'investissement mais du coup il faut
ouais il faut des entraîneurs il faut
une méthodologie et des gens motivés
qu'ils veulent et après sur la masse bon
bah tu fasses mentorat attendre alors
que ça marchera pas trop mais tu vas te
s'ouvre sur des pupitres
mais je pense que les tailles d'eternit
restait pas moins un échec du coup tout
est une question d'argent dans ce monde
bah ouais non mais en fait c'est
[Musique]
pourtant investi en fait forcément les
esprits
c'était en fait ah oui au fait c'est
chris et claire qui alors leur équipe
ouais c'est beaucoup de joueurs qui
étaient étrangers à la base soit caruana
soit sow dominguez ou comme et qui
vivent là-bas depuis un moment qui
servent d'exemples qui motive les plus
jeunes et les universités aussi qui
recrutent et donc pas mal de jeunes
joueurs à potentiel qui sont formés et c
est en fait c'est un truc vertueux mais
sami longtemps en fait à apprendre aux
états unis c'était un truc sur une
grosse dizaine d'années ouais je crois
que trop d'espoir pour le match en
famille non mais mon niveau 1 niveau des
filles chez que les états unis l'ont
investi récemment beaucoup au niveau
difficile à gérer ce type
[Musique]
j'avais deux leçons sont prometteuses et
voilà ils vont plaindre c'est clair et
bonjour aux gens qui viennent de youtube
un joli le chat youtube
en même temps vous serez mis au goût et
à tayrac irak
caisse est sûre je sais pas pourquoi sa
reine ainsi cette affaire sont que 3 mai
place du sport en fait il est mal à
chaque fois par la porte avant la radio
gagner mais parce qu'ils étaient bien
les ajustements et est embrouillé avant
mais ouais après les parties
s'enchaînent t'as pas forcément la wii
et devait gagner mais il ya eu les
piaules les pionniers latu s'était même
engagé mais il n'a pas daigné non la
pagani mais l'heure est à l arrêt dire
mais c'est pas grâce à l'ouverture
non c'est sûr mais du coup ils comptés
mais quand tu es mal dans un match
qu'ils ont fait avec les noirs tu
souffrais clémente à prendre l'aventage
faux seins faux changé tu peux pas
rejouer le même truc du tam aeternam et
vous avez fait quoi et la pointe deux
fois le puits ans et 4 pts 6 rb 4 passes
et reprend d'autrefois
c'était bien de hockey bros commerce un
peu moins alors une cible ans et sept
mois je pense mais bon t'as pas encore
gagné 4,6 m
le fait qu'on tente de faire quelques
foulées sens que je pense mais cinq
cavaliers c3 et quoi nature par qui
régnait alors il a fait cas ici il ya un
autre coup soutient que j'aurais pu
envisager cette f4 mais bon pour
l'instant lire les possibilités à chaque
fois où chaque foyer prend f5
j'aime pas sa façon de réagir au centre
sera cépage est impatient qu'elle
devrait pas non mais là faut qu'elle
voit plus rien ouais c'est ça devient
tendu et qu'elle voulait td fois qu'ils
attribuent leur exemple une reine damien
obligé et des trois quilles et où
l'attend mais bon faut dire que tu as
trop sûrement que deux tu as deux pions
en moins tu peux plus de paires de foot
l écueil qui vont arriver demain c'est
dommage parce que ouais mais c'est ce
format en fait c'est quand tu consens la
tête sous l'eau s'était même pas le
temps de souffler et puis tu as pu le
coeur à l'ouvragé quoi ce que fait faut
gagner une partie
la phrase de mire tu as gagné une partie
est peut-être peut repartir de l'avant
s'ils n'ont pas tous non j'essaie de
rapprocher ma chaise
mais je fais 1 m 50 m les brevets donc
pas facile pour moi c'est une chose de
streamer c'est une ergonomie c'est bien
c'est pour la colonne et two way il ya
un truc un soutien
la stam c'est top
m et romarin c'est la gagne est connu
l'histoire va-t-elle pour ça le moment à
passer
et du coup le timer tu sais forêt pardon
alors il reste 12 minutes 12 minutes de
souffrance encore plus le budget ouais
mais j'ai bon espoir qu'on sert en
bullet ouais sauf que là une bonne dose
peut pointer tout ça c'est bon espoir
en tout cas j'espère qu'elle va revenir
un peu plus rapide allait passer une
soirée pas mal joué au cap d'agde dont
elle avait joué le c'était quand même un
nom de ouais ouais bah après c'était
juste un temps dans un buisson 6 et il
avait annulé
il est venu les je sais plus pourquoi
ils avaient quand même invité les gens à
moi je devais je devais jouer notre
quart parfait c'était l'année où il a
même dit malheureusement des années en
fait maintenant j'ai jamais eu tout le
temps je suis perdu tu vois je peux plus
de dire 2016 une quinzaine de noms mais
ouais clairement
par contre elle est vice-championne du
monde en blitz et rapide 1 c'est une
pointure normalement mais mais après sur
internet c'est complètement différent
que ne seront pas d'enfilades en vrai
pointu dira pas mais c'est clair c'est
très différent rien que la vision 3d 2d
et la motivation et l'ambiance et voilà
c'est déjà beau mais quand tu quand tu
touches les pièces et ça donne plus
d'adrénaline je trouve mais même la
vision du jeu ouais je crois que c est
un genre en voie j'ai du mal à mettre
une puce en prison je sais pas ses
forces et de ses pas et sur internet je
peux vraiment fier des trucs je ferai
pas ouais ouais ok et je pense que des
gens c'est l'inversé ceux qui ont
beaucoup jeux sur internet
ouais c'est incroyable leur match sur un
vrai chic et ils peuvent faire des
conneries tu fais pas c'est juste vision
qui change
je suis beaucoup plus je l'avais quand
même d'accord j'aurais tendance à moi
donc bon c'est le choix est fait
d'ordinaire mes amis dont chacun sache
où ça joue beaucoup mieux sur un vrai
chic est question d'un badge aime pas je
sais c'est simple j'ai même pas vraiment
plaisir à faire moi ça dépend à ces
dates et sita détournant un jeu aux dés
fois que tu joues contre des mecs fort
par exemple moi pas typiquement quand je
vais sur internet parce que parce que je
stream
mais quand joe jean letaille telles
puces des ou des trucs des trucs comme
ça j'ai tendance à me concentrer
beaucoup plus franchement à chaque fois
que j'ai fait le title j'ai toujours
fait des supers réseau
j'ai déjà battu des gm et ses amis et
quand je blitz normale sans son sac à
main je moi j'ai tendance à très très
facilement donner des pièces
donc ça se dépensa dépendant jeu se
dépense en huit heures ça dépend de
plein de trucs
c'est clair qu'en général sur internet
si c'est dur non mais vraiment j'aime
bien paraître pour le pour tous les
trucs comme ça qu'on monte discuter
chaque passer des bons moments mais ça
c'est cool en fait ça est vraiment pu
arrêter le jeu et toucher de nouvelles
personnes
et justement des gens de la question
s'il faut les enclaves ou pas des gens
qui rompt jamais en club mais qui du
coup peuvent jouer peuvent découvrir des
trucs à apprendre c'est ça c'est top
parce qu'en fait d'aller en club c'est
quand même spécial enfin là qui vont
adorer ne doute pas du tout mais c'est
une ambiance peut-être plus compétition
ou ne sera pas toujours forcément très
bien reçu je sais pas en fait d avoir
des trucs comme ça mais pas toujours
très sympa ça va dépendre mais tu peux
voir plusieurs retours mais meiway les
compétitions sont hadj du man à derrick
qui comme annick imedi perso c'est
internet je mets des pièces emprise mais
un vrai jeu mais des pièces emprise du
coup ça se joue pas l'attitude très bon
alors cette partie voilà la noble de
saône est sorti pas mal de l'ouverture
were volet blandford être aussi quelques
rayé des deux mois dix ans bien ces
trois tu peux direction des 5 mais c'est
un peu lent et du coq les noirs ça a
l'air d'aller
ça a l'air d'aller cette fois de me 3
j'aime bien ça cloud
non mais moins du coup août on pousse le
travail de tu peux sans de prendre des
baies quatre marques avant un cadavre à
cette station total reste 7 minutes dans
la portion entre +1 donc c'est là y
avoir une autre
bon ça recommence le pit tactique et ce
point pas mal de tahiti pas en forme
5 ça va arriver
parmi les grands jours ouais ouais bah
du coup maintenant c'est clair que les
moyens soient un groupe pour moi cette
cadence et simple qui comme sa buse de
vouloir lui faire tour processus est fou
des singes ok la savane tour d'élite
s'est vite mais quelle joie f3 wever m
et à son tour d'être au top un petit
contrat j'ai fait je n'aime pas ces
artistes hors ces deux je sais pas j'ai
pas envie d'être de la gestion d'un
emploi et bercy samedi à katif et mes
cours
un bon j'ai pas trop attendait 3 c'est
leur logique eu les nerfs s'active à
trouver le c6 le tour dix huit des six
bon c'est pas la super actif mais bon
qu'est ce qu'on en fait se foutent façon
c'est peut-être possible de mettre 1,8
patapon si tu peux pas tu lui même et ça
peu bizarre tu as laissé l'autre
fourniront des 5
c'était calme plat le projet de base
mais ok on entend ce que tu vas faire un
est ce que tu vas faire b4 n'ont
peut-être pas tu essaies de la caisse et
4 je sais pas quoi dire pour les noirs
comme quoi faire je pense que tu dois
rester comme ça de chiens dans la
pression justement actif et qui est
blond aux galères à bouger et qui bouge
times
bon alors on peut peut-être envisager
franck a pas trop fait on essaie tout ce
que damas vite il enfila des invasions
ils font là oui c'est vrai avant la
finale comme injuste après exactement là
donc là c'est un peu la muse bouche jeu
comme ça ils se réchauffent et calculé
deux trois trucs et après la grande
finale donc on rappelle sa même finale
de la dernière fois les deux mêmes
joueuses ou chez lui ou chez nina et
valentina colina est originaire avait
gagné la première fois donc c'est un peu
la revanche il va voir à voir si ça
tourne aussi chez nina assoit sa
domination sur cette compétition
au final tactique est qui marchent pas
parent
juste à temps avec un ton plus rien pcf
set peut-être ça risque de faire 2,5 et
puis plus rien quoi qui piège mais sur
un camion des cinq films voilà lors du
dam des cinq lacs et puis maintenant
sarraute h4 bien jeu et se prend des
cases d'amd 5 toujours sur le 8 qui
affirmaient de 9,7 pouces et aller
retour déjà se jouer demain je vais même
rappeler que tu peux même te permettre
le luxe de répéter la position 5 à 5 ça
fait mal et puis tu prends ça aurait été
pion de l'autre côté une énorme
recrutement du hockey y va avec [ __ ]
au carnage ce match si la forme et
roches ou trois ça fait autre chose mais
je vous parle j'ai oublié non mais juste
ça tu peux pas faire quand t'as pas une
fois le hamas allait être le faire alors
pour 8,5 près par cinq en fait mais je
sais que cinq dirais que c'est jouable
pour la qualité avec un 10 h 4
qu'attendre comme ça
jouer n'est pas que c'était petits dés
que blank et jouer la gamme fait
d'accord donc l'expert de couleurs non
c'est l'expérience tu prendras quelques
couleurs j'aime bien et noir enfin ça
c'est plus ouvert j'ai une tendance à
penser que je sais pas se fout des deux
n'est pas au point d'en [ __ ] à toi tu
aimes bien il rayonne sur les bandes
rivales et aux 4,5 à patates a peur
qu'on te fasse là comme ça à fabrice tu
bosses tu peux pas te contraire est vrai
que je me sens départ mais c'était pas
bon parce que il y avait un des quatre
afin d' accord à hauteur de 8 mais bon
les dauphins mais au moins là pour le
coup je prendrais plutôt les blancs
blassac si tu te fais tous fixés sur
carte blanche ça petit alors s'il faut à
24 tu as le plus c'est simple mais bon
ça saute tu peux tu donnes qualité mais
bon logique pas faire ça well et non en
fait il rêverait bloquer les quinze
manches 1
ouais
non c'est pas simple pour le monde pas
faux ouais je serai bientôt quatre ans
il n'y a pas de couilles
ouais c'est via le français 3 quand même
c'est pas une décision facile à prendre
non c'est clair encore revenir dessus
nous allons n'aime pas du tout du tout
vous donner son fou de fumier tôt
clairement on n'a pas le trou sur 15
morts mais bien jugé qu'en fait les
blancs mais pas arrivé si vite si on
vous ferez de dents qu'elle est géré
tout ça est offert bien je serai que ce
pont fut belle décision ou être tout
était question de contrôle des quinze
manches en fait c'est un oxymore pardon
bien que ouais c'est la compagnie je
saignais henry coach bowie champions
je suis plus le matin place y est tu
vois il est super heureux ce sera un
cocorico
qu'est-ce qui me dit avec sa vtt vie
balocco kipré contre narbonne a déjà
parlé chaussée une extension de chrome
et je dise pas chrome donc je ne vais
pas sur queen sur tee-shirt brave c'est
un navigateur
on a parlé via en fait sur les bugs et
bien ouais c'est pas mal au niveau de la
preuve à 6 au niveau des détraqués en
fait ça veut dire tous les trackers et
ça va très vite non ouais t'as pas de
pub pas rien ça ouais franchement en
scène bon moi je suis plutôt sur sur
chrome coiffure oui comme si j'avais
gagné et je sais pas d'ailleurs juste en
platine parle de ça mais bon personne en
moins de quatre heures
alors bon écoute tout est possible cette
partie oui
oui je comprends que c'est une extension
est ce qu'elle est valable aussi sur
brave ça la question
et ce sera quoi du coup ce bêtisier soi
que cette semaine des imode spéciaux
which way les émeutes
je met des femmes dans le chalet manquer
ça
c'est plein de trucs bien par nous tuer
tous a besoin des deux trucs automatisé
matin moi je suis comme un mois pas dit
tu dois m'installer bt tv jeunesse n'a
pas bien été mais moi je ne suis qu un
sous fifre
je respecte les consignes de same way
peut-être cavalli t3 la petite fourche à
la fourchette as attention bronche pas
pourtant je souhaite quand même c'est
trop et fuient à leur tour des de hockey
bon bah peut-être des cinq way dont g7
pour les fuites 3,7 récupération pure de
moins
mais du coup l'eau tous rapports entre
états tours 8 voilà bien joué mais je
pense que je sens que ça va mal tourner
pour ça encore ben moi j'ai plus
confiance
je pourrais faire la surprise
quelles décisions à la petite répétition
découlent voilà ça répète on pas de tour
ces deux alors ça prend ça prend ça joue
le bien-fonds mais pourquoi pas le
garçon forcément fairway c'est bien au
nom assez bon ben là il ya quelque temps
des 2 tours 3 2
droite santa marta catherine fierté pour
ces deux noms tu peux pas prendre le
clientèle vers f7 bon ok je te fais un
petit échec
ouais bah oui il ya un corps qui jouent
pour la victoire c'est plutôt les tue
énormément attention le roi arrive
délirant g5 tout est possible que ça
part dans tous les sens l'impression qui
a quand même pas moi c'est une fois que
tu fais tous les pions au oui encore et
voilà parfait bon allez est ce que ça
aurait va gagner celle-là est ce que tu
es prêt à t'engager moi je m'engage
c'est un gage ce clanwar le bloc est
déjà viré en fait donc être fort je veux
pas trop comment georges préfère boîte
car la fougue et dvd est foutue aux
aveux
à 20 h salle bayard il est inquiet quand
même je croque leroy revient mais c'est
bien la faire durer la partie chrétien
échec
il est resté et bien plié [ __ ] donc là
du coup sur la tête du coach cathy
sarraï fait ça n'ont cessé demi heure et
demie il ya cinq parties à remonter
cette fois non pas que je alors je meurs
stoppés dans leur élan
ouais bon bah premier point pour ça se
perd on sait mais je pense que même
physiquement elle a pas le temps de
suivre une formation et je vis je vais
te dire ça mathématiquement c'est déjà
perdu quoi c'est possible elle le chapon
du s'est suffi ouais voilà ces dix
minutes donc un mois radiophonique
ouailles c'est ça paraît très très
chouette encore jouer vite et bien ça
paraît même même un faisable j'ai envie
de dire impossible n'est pas n'est pas
sa race quesque ouais je vais axer vise
cinq matches du berger voilà c'est ça
j'ai peut-être aller prendre une pause
mois vas-y postwar je vais je me posais
parlé avec avec les gars je peux arrêter
avec les gars sur big bill à la commande
mur tu as semé marcheurs bitstream
n'attendent pas ça mais bon tu peux te
répondre puisque fischer je trouverais
situation normes si chaud en fait le
problème c'est que ça dépend trop de
sarah quoi au fait si si katia est
normalement que c'était dur est parti
jarre deux minutes déjà ça suffit alors
pourquoi y'a paquets venant hp bab
je pense que vous pouvez prendre son
dimanche qu'elle quoi en fait et comment
tu es un peu tous les jours ce tournoi
mais c'est dur il perdre encore en fait
c'est bon c'est est spécialement conçu
quand même ces quatre fois même temps
une sorte de classement général auront
fait qu'on soit tout le temps la même
chose tous les jours tous les jours tu
as une petite pause un moment et puis il
y aura d'autres posent sont prochaine
aussi j'arrive à les récupérer bruit
souccar donc on refera avec contre je
crois
vendredi et dimanche prochain ou un truc
comme ça m'est donc j'ai donc l air du
temps ils gèrent le truc très bien voilà
est ce que je sache si kiev stream au jo
aujourd'hui je sais pas mais peut-être
peut-être peut-être ce soir redemander
je sais pas s'il a mis un tweet ou quoi
faute chez care comme dirait monsieur
l'ex de s'être immolé du rps forme a
manqué ce web à sa forme
ok j'ai des fois je comprends pas ce qui
se passe je prêche moralisateur donc
mais oui tu cherches on peut trouver des
formats plus sympa qui nous ont pondu
depuis quelques mois à droite à gauche
ça pue lisible plus facile il ya un
match france danemark ce soir au quai
pour que les frères laudrup pss michael
tout ça les séries
michel 28
joe cocker en stream je sais pas donc
vers quelle heure vers 20h ce match
contre le danemark vikings d'alain
essensis un peu à petit il faut si oui
bah forcément c'est le même format les
mêmes joueuses le même bruit court est
en fait tu dois une fois c'est sympa de
fois vous voilà maintenant quatre fois
et ils vont ce soir et le week-end
prochain exactement vers les leaders jeu
sera calme donc je pourrait accueillir
bourhis hooker sa nouvelle maison
j'ai failli amener m j le chien quoi
qu'ils fassent connaissance mais bon
peut-être le toit et comme sur scène
finale alors ça avance et un peu
imprévisible soit deux fois en finale
femme est donc un stream chien prévu hot
chip
il valait plus mort esuba je crois qu'il
veut lui donner un prénom normale entre
10 entre guillemets mais ce sera juste
un prénom officiel pour ses papiers mais
en fait le vrai prénom c'est clair que
c'est pour une soupe personne va
l'appeler avec un autre nom parce que je
suis une coquerelle coq le patois de
contente de faire cinq heures de voiture
ouais mais dans quoi et boris tout cas
je serais content de quatre peut-être
que je serai son parrain je ne sais pas
si ça a été attribué les places des
places d'honneur
que j'amène pas ça c'est clair que nos
coqs qui du coup fait celui de coqs ici
il est très bien mais ouais demain est
donc moi je direction de cannes donc
demain soir un an je serai avec kiev
pour une partie pédagogique façon fait
parce que tu as vu lundi semences l
heureux si tu fais un petit
wen un petit café finalement jamais
battu ouais ça marche pas mais je prends
encore la même petite touchette de tulle
et de soja nataf ont donc tous et auquel
ce coin de temps tu fais tout ça et j'ai
vu juste à rennes depuis un nom ok t'as
pas fait craquage si des fois de temps
en temps en fait le principe d'être
végétarien je trouve c'est pas produire
de la demande
donc en fait des fois j'en par exemple
si au resto du commun hendrix et en juin
mais quitte en emportant avec devient
bon bah je le pense je ne sais pas c'est
pas gâcher quoi donc
si l'effet des filles voilà autant mangé
pas le chercher
ouais c'est des fois ça m'arrive de ces
m'arrive de faire des entorses
mais c'est pour la bonne cause bon c'est
un peu comme ça aussi c'est cool c'est
bien ok mais ouais je sais pas moi je
suis pas de régime spécial
non mais
bon honnêtement le lait de vache je le
digère plus louche a donc du coup
j'avais lait de chèvre j'aime pas sûr
d'en avoir déjà bu en fait tu veux plus
fun time
désolé j'ai pas faire tchèque czech
times je suis ce que de stages ou stores
appli alors n'ont ni son renom le
premier set était remplie mais bien des
c'est à dire qu un souci qu advienne on
casse une place pour le premier et il
reste trois quatre places pour le second
donc il ya toujours des dix possibles
vous voulez vous aimez écrire par mail
vous pouvez checker mon twitter et
toutes les infos je peux mettre le lien
si vous voulez nous allons pouvoir le
bas qui va dire stop snam inc whitling
ouais mais bon je trouve à tout ce que
je vois là japy péter seddon je suis pas
sûr en fait des bonds pour le coup j'ai
essayé puis ça a marché
j'envoie des roses j'envoie dpsk jambes
et des trucs
histoire de faire oublier par informer
votre genre est dédé voilà les oiseaux
peuvent femme voilà ça consiste en quoi
les stages bas ça consiste à faire un
entraînement des chèques en fait sur
quatre jours donc il y aura ce qui est
prévu c'est six heures d'échec chaque
jour donc deux sessions une même
atteindre 9 à 12 petite pause midi une
autre de 14 à 17
et on va aborder plusieurs thèmes ce
sera deux sages différent sera pas deux
fois le sujet mais ce sera assez
complète je veux faire je pense
entraînement au calcul c'est important
ça parle à tout le monde c'est cool puis
des thèmes dans le jeu j'ai pensé à
prendre la prophylaxie faut être un truc
intéressant
e j'aurais bien voulu aborder un thème
autour des pions doublé sur des finales
les plus des finales pratique que des
finales les finales en fait théorique on
les a dans tous les livres qu'il n'y
aurait pas de valeur ajoutée
mais les finales qu'on a en pratique
c'est peut être peu de coulvain bref je
crois pas les ouvertures y aura
peut-être kiev rassemblement qui pourra
dans le coin vu qu'on sera choisi une
salle dans un hôtel jeudi 8 à pied de
chez lui donc ce sera pas là pour les
cours ou quoi mais on pourra le voir
pour l'équipe fourchette qui arrivait
voilà donc je ferai pas mon programme je
prépare les cours tout puis page écart
sera bien voilà c'est ça le fond mais
bon c'est peut-être pas fini de prendre
le 3e et whisky et c'est ouvert à tous
les niveaux a enfin oui et non il n'y a
pas de règles mais en fait en gros je
sais de faire un truc un peu homogène
donc en gros entre 13 cents à 17,120 la
presse il fermerait pas les vérifier les
vélos pile poil quelque 1750 peut être
là quelqu'un qui a peut-être 1280 ou qui
jouent sur internet qui pensent qu'ils
pensent être pas mal
il n'y a pas de souci je vais pas faire
la police mais faux paquets de trop de
disparités dans le niveau qui saperait
pas regarder qui s'ennuie ou d'autres
pour qu'il soit trop difficile donc à un
groupe homogène je pense les mieux ou là
mais c'est encore se font dans tous les
sens on retourne je pense que j'ai
bon là ça va quand même un film qui suit
est heureuse de la pop après le projet a
pris corps de l'être
enfin tu vois c'est possible tout est
réalisable ce jeu de la vie quoi alors
me sort jusqu'à ce que natation darmon
stages de langues disent ah bon je pense
mais c'est peut-être un peu léger mais
pouvez m'écrire en fait les au cas où de
façon c'est pas pour ce stage là une
aura peut-être d'autres à l'avenir ou
d'autres trucs donc n'hésitez pas à le
prendre des renseignements en tassant
sans drm écrivez moi un message sur le
twitter ce par mail à l'adresse malik
sur la fiche du stage sur sur
l'installation d'un porte nous pourrons
discuter mais wiland si vous êtes 1000
ou quoi je pense enfin moi je préfère en
plein stage mais pour vous c'est
peut-être des alpes
du coup cette partie mais la g25 direct
au lieu de trois ouah c'est pas du
n'importe quoi le bullet c'est surtout
les réflexes j'ai l'impression que c'est
à des très bonnes bases
alors tu es une très bonne utilisation
du coude et très prolixe mais bon on
défend fait je crois que je vais vite et
tu ça favorise les joueurs qui comprenne
bien je pense le bullet
en fait j'aime bien mais en fait moi
maintenant je fais plus que des bulles
est moche ouais et demie moi j'ai je
perd patience très vite en 3 + 2 ou 1 3
c'est pas constater que je donnerai mes
élèves je le fais c'est marrant ça oui
en fait c'est pas pour progresser aux
échecs
attention tu peux pas prendre le fou
parce qu'il ya cette fourchette mais du
coup lequel des deux est peut-être
menaçant envers il est écrit que devoir
jongler
ouais je pourrais si à l'occasion
papapapa la tasse on n'est pas là pour
commenter quand on parle beaucoup et
tout c'est là sa petite finale et je
crois que l'enjeu oui
dirigé depuis un moment mais non
traduits en bullet à l'occaz quand je
serai shakey vous quoi chauffer à
sourire c'est important dans la souris
en main de fer des maïs il peut pas
faire et les déchets k4 tu joues un peu
ou pas ouais j'ai un peu fait est alors
temps de jeu c'est très compliqué si la
stratégie qui marche super bien
voilà ton tour de l'ain c'est eh bien
voilà c'est fini tout ça c'est au tour
d'honneur suite en profite mais dur et
non c'est une stratégie
et ce tandis que marche super bien j'ai
l'impression sa sortir la dame super tôt
et que temps l'autre mec de ton équipe
certain adam super tôt et j'écoute avec
sally contre moi je suis très énervé à
chaque but
ok je foutrais pleutre il se fait
d'accord ça m'énerve mais ouais non je
débute en tant que je peux faire
mais il y avait le jeu reste fort ça qui
serait bien c'est débile c'est le buzz
avec ça tu choisis tes pièces au départ
la langue de points après deux fois que
ça joue tout seul puis qu'en fait c'est
n'importe quoi mais j'ai cru que ça va
être un truc bien
pas de chance le jeu où tu ta voix tu un
capital de points de départ avec moi ça
fait un peu comme les fantaisies tu as
un budget quad hong kong arme de poing
greta position de départ mais tu vois
une stratégie au taux de ch est-ce ça et
on fait déjà de pas jouer la partie que
ça joue tout seul c'est pas top
enfin jouer et puis en fait au point pas
trop de casse trop le bordel je bats tu
peux mettre du goûte tu vas te faire
défoncer des fous et déjà prendre des
fautes par tout est d'amener tout savoir
où aller
et du coup elles ont choisi de vous
prendre que les fous toi
la stratégie assez simple tuer les
[ __ ] partout
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
du coup elle aimait l'appeler sione wade
veut ça bon alors si bel et bien un
petit peu de plantes et de france 3 voit
la f4 aux intermédiaires montrent qu'ils
allaient repartir j'imagine mémoire sd
en fait ouais bref de roger un web et
loire pour 25
pas mal mais c'est pas encore gagné pour
gagner je l'a d'ailleurs 3,6 kg 4 très
bonne défense attention avertit cavalia
2 qui était menacée je pense est-ce
qu'on peut juste revoir au ralenti ouais
au ralenti là en fait qui pose en khl et
les blancs ne fasse rien
moi ce que je pense oui genre tu
apprends à six cavaliers de taux prend
hélas on a ce magnifique match du
couloir
donc aujourd'hui joli joli
oh ça y est enfin allé au sahara est
lancé dommage le match est fini mais
vaut mieux tard que jamais il reste 10
minutes 15 sur l'a6 avant la période où
l'avant dernière sinon ça va vite mais
quand je joue plus non c'était trop
compliqué et tout le monde connaît en
plus j'ai l'impression maintenant les 18
sont ces déblais de théorie donc j'ai
joint un truc un peu plus rampant genre
denims ou des des quads et hollandaises
[Musique]
mais l'inra d'un peu de tout mais bon
c'est quoi c'est chaque fois nifff
non mme exemple si c'est trop c'est trop
théorique et game guerre qui le joue
bien il est né peau quand même niveau
des 8 leur arrivera comme quelques-uns à
me faire nullement un nul au niveau des
dames g3 d'un match trois magistrats je
crois déjà commis et puis peut-être plus
si affinités je sais pas quand non ouais
sauf que cette fois c'est soit laide et
fouetter
[Musique]
ça va pas il ya peu d'hommes de trois
mois lors d'un match au tournoi tu fais
tu forces allemandes ont peut-être
encore plus fort ouais ouais ouais ouais
bon bah voilà c'était c'est la fin de ce
match
donc ok pas très équilibré et coiffé de
mi 2007
oui risques aux rebonds captés finale va
être plus plus discutés et qu'est ce que
je vais dire petite finale ouais ça
qu'est la sava
un week-end à 16h09 dans quelques
minutes je pense un peu de piano thierry
karl et demi au pire si je regardais les
stream anglais normalement ils vont dire
ça commence sa carrière sur le c'est
sûrement là c'est robert s non c'est
bienne jade inhérents à narbonne est
mort quand même quand même revers est au
dessus de tout acabit propos qui pousse
les la française à fond mais bravo je
passe et acheter le dvd côté des sites a
besoin du pont-du-las française tourne
[Musique]
pas mal parce que souvent les joueurs
qui jouent quatre ils sont pas vraiment
aussi préparé quelques surprises en plus
4 5 ou 6 sur les céciliennes je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu plus
sortir des sentiers battus ouais ouais
c'est stratégique et les offenses pas
encore né on est sur tous les fronts a
par exemple dans le match dans le match
contre sofia labit stream est j'ai
beaucoup joué l'offre française jacques
laffont ouais ouais j'avais je vais
trouver quelques idées javert
un peu bosser donc franchement c'était
pas moi ça s'est bien passé pour moi
s'enchaîne à fond que michaëlle jean
voit des 900 grammes papy boom pow et
yale dvd bon bah du coup j'espère que ça
a porté ses fruits
il ya un autre dvd qui sort demain en
vue au parquet la moder ça peut te
plaire aussi tu peux là je vois la fia
est une sorte de française de l'autre
côté du coup ok on va suivre votre côté
gecina battait pour qui pour moi aussi
[Musique]
je sais pas si on peut changer de photo
nature ne faudra voilà je ne te vois tu
es nul vous dégage j'ai un boulot et je
photo photo
manina aller de 3,84 gelé j elle tape
par follow quand tu l'as follow et une
polo bat sara tu dégages ouais bon
écoute a marqué quelques points pour ce
tournoi on la reverra dans les deux
prochains la cour ça se passe bon du
coup ça se fait par la position c
comment expliquer qu'on fait les noirs
jouent comme si c'était un grand vide à
accepter que les bleus ont pas fait les
quatre ont dû attendre mais je suis se
réserve le droit de le faire ou quoi
c'est un peu du jeu de chat et de la
souris quoi mais donc les blancs et
dorés de le faire leur sont bien prêts
là je pense que c'était à eux de jouer
il serait presque pas joué des cartes et
observer cinq valoir qu' ils sont fous
j'imagine en d3 et l'autre idée qu'on
peut régler l'angle parfait des cas
c'était à 4 pour essayer de provoquer un
truc chez les noirs gerber 4 et ce
moment là on va à la caste et 4 pour y
mettre un cavalier ou quoi bref voilà
j'aime bien sûr mais aussi s'était dit
de nous faut bien un
et d'essayer de jouer sur mon bras quoi
ouais bah ça peut tomber rav4 oxnard
n'impacte pas fou points à 7 h pas tout
chauffe et j'ai vu qu'elle fut noir
cerclé sur le sacré message a du coffre
est tellement de vous laisser quelqu'un
achète
je viens j'ai plein de gens qui vivent
plus ou moins détruites en voile à
partir en gif et saskia des vocations de
cette édition h7 ses collègues et du
coup non j'ai l'impression que la
vanille mais je sais pas plus de
potentiel dans sa poésie peut-être la
mythique fouet au regard de la golf r
kelly ces trois ou quatre je pense
prochain cahier pcistes qui défend bien
le roi et puis après elles ont envoyé
tannage 5 heures est retombé j'aime bien
les faits de jeu et de conviction bat
cécile typiquement son nom son style de
jeu aussi un très dynamique pour des
tactiques de la peur de rien je me dis
qu'est l'art ça ne craint personne
mais bon là du coup les regards
peut-être tu me l'as je regarde bien
c'est à dire quand même un truc et jaya
peut-être tu l'as cannes france et 5 et
surtout prendre un match 5 double
attaque mais il y avait cinq double
défense donc escale mais en fait non
mais bon voilà on sait jamais des fois
des trucs comme ça ça peut marcher
mon bon moment il ya tous et toutes ses
défenses au buzz 2,5 me dans un futur
proche pour le projet 4 à ce moment là
j'ai quatre dg capte par 30 chaque année
au qui demandait un truc on dit que
quand il ya plus de dom on est en finale
alors hein pourquoi on dit qu'il ya des
finales de dames
en fait c'était change tout le reste la
plus que les dames basse et une finale
de dame est de 2,6 juste un cran vers
saddam est ce que c'est une finale ça
dépend ça dépendra d'abord la dame
perdue faut gérer ça se passe mal
apprécié ces mêmes sacrifier contre
entre tours et fou de tous trois pièces
ou quoi à voir mais en fait la finale
scotia plus trop trop de pièces très
chic et quand même ouais c'est un beau
feeling mais genre là pour que je puisse
appeler ça une finale genre si tu
m'enlèves les deux tours et la dame
solution je peux dire voici au final
mais si t'enleve et le cavalier chacun
est de fous ça serait pas une finale
pour moi donc c'est pas le nombre de
pièces vraiment mais ces invasions que
les joueurs sont plus ou moins de bon
après on fait on est pour sa part en
scène six ans sur deux jours oui oui ce
film montre le roi bah oui et non parce
que messieurs mesdames messieurs des
finales de pièces lourdes ça existe et
puis j'étais pas forcément censée monter
l'aura donc j'aime bien ce que tu aies
joué je veux bien aller aller vanilla on
se sort les doigts
allez prends ta revanche bon elle est
mieux façon qu'on a dit allez vous
craquer vers le roi bon c4 c'est pas mal
ce qu'elle fait quand même chine a bien
joué son coup et l'autre truc c'est que
wes depuis aussi ce qui était plutôt
faible mais vu comment ça se passe n'est
pas à l'échangé des quatre de ses cinq
noms qu'on aurait pu avoir le temps de
le faire avant et peut-être que je sais
pas si clair alors oui j'ai
pour revenir sur des caméras des jeunes
j'aurais bien voulu 1
c'était non c'était censé être le cas
mais j'ai perçu l'appel par le lien du
col provoque donc je n'ai pas et caméras
mais je les aurai mise un bien sûr de
quel plus beau désolé votre langue ils
l'ont mais juste le nouveau prix bas
mais je pense que vu que c'est moi qu'il
fait et package pas je pense qu'ils ont
dû oublier de demain ajouté à la
couvrait le jeune florence rault top oui
le micromarché direct par les caméras
tout même déjà a déjà et j'étais pas mal
quand même parce que bon c'est un
bosseur il m'a dit en gros c'est sûr
qu'il ya un truc qui marchera pas mais
t'inquiète pas tu vas gérer comme je
tombe dans cette allée de paniquer pour
bien confiance et il m'a dit inquiète
c'est sûr y'a un truc et mangera pas
mais surtout je panique pas donc non à
savoir finalement ça c'est ça s'est bien
passé au niveau de la technique à savoir
marcher pour l'instant mais bah on n'a
pas encore fini on sait pas quoi oui
mais c'est ma première fois hors il est
effectivement c'est pour ça que j'étais
un peu tendu mais ça va
donc qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
position est celle pas en fait j'aime
bien et blanc toujours j'aime bien la
formule les blancs ah ouais c'est énorme
avantage qu'elle a elle à 2 minutes 25
secondes donc vacances et comme ça en
fait faut pas s'enflammer je veux tout
tempo c'est le meilleur moyen terme mais
en gros quelques des trucs compliqués
c'est peut être bien justement d'aperam
a trop le temps et c'est quoi ces trois
plus un autre opus de n 1 ici c'est
simple et sain et à chaque fois c'est
plus un ok voilà coiffés en fait gaffe à
pas se prendre de cette découverte
ouais bah c'est chaud voilà il ya
vachement de trucs emprise je sais même
pas quel conseiller exactement cinq
thèmes gk 2005 salaires possible d'aimer
5 très bien
il a quoi sa vrai gagnant me faut encore
travailler un petit coin descloix
j'agirai dans tous les sens mme khalip
pas trop bouger aussi l x 3 ans l'ait
repérée à tour c'est un défendeur cet
ancien de défendre le fou bien le
kallisté cinq fois on peut vite se faire
arnaquer c'est vraiment hors de l'inde
ouais ok bon ce même idée c'est bien
c'est bien c'est d'avoir du cloître
prendre ces dames qu'on aime ou pas au
revoir tout est possible non mais kg
bonne foi allez il faut quatre noms se
met en marche et ouais cool ce que
attaque la dame
il ya dans cet hymne ans on peut prendre
la d'amorcer reprendre la nôtre mais il
faut des cinq échecs ou quoi même finale
avec un son de cloche
ce sera débarrassé toutes les pièces
j'aurais j'aurais fait ça aussi c'est
cool on va voir la pointe de vitesse de
chine a pas qu'elle joue vite et les
blancs gère bien
j'aime bien ça se passe bien well as
bien joué à la tactique et la finale
marin qui pompe plus avoir besoin pourra
convertir mais c'est pas mal au pire
ouais tu l'as où tu vois la cigale c'est
bien en chine
oui dont c'était bien elle va sûrement
faire à 4 après oui à la foux ton temps
et d'être surtout b6
oui ça va devenir un problème au bout
d'un certain temps j'ai pas mal le
changement fouet la forme était pour sa
7ème j'aime beaucoup
septième citoyen est ce que tu auras des
tours à sept blocs le roi adverse tu
attaques g7 au passage donc l homme d
progressivement qu'elle va gagner
deuxième pion même pas besoin de le
stresser et vont de viande bio c'est
vraiment beaucoup
un plus en bullet vanina et gère plutôt
bien
c'est une très bonne joueuse et bullet
on va quand on voit pousser le pion au
bout d'un moment
ouais au cours de leur vie non mais en
fait oui à hiesse hockey avantages web
prendre son temps du coup j'aimerais
avoir un peu sur quoi tourner le match
ok système de long des trois sapeurs
n'est pas des blogs des cas et des cinq
cd il faut garder chaque alors oui vous
pouvez ou quoi est ce que c'est normal à
force de traîner chaque de commencer à
vraiment apprécier final nous apprennent
j'avais consulté
what a peut-être un problème toute façon
dans l'échec est mêlé final il n'y a pas
de souci c'est une belle partie du jeu
c'est mais là je pense c'est peut-être
ça a l'air super bien j'ai tout faire
pour les blancs si un gars tarifs 3 du
coup mais bon marché et se dit
absolument aussi mais à leur sort ce
caoutchouc ou alors la de la chance je
sais pas mais quand tu dis ou sechin on
sait où julie na waie
et ouais bon les finales c'est un autre
partie du jeu en fait tu joues plus pour
faire mettre ces c'est autre chose
ça donne envie de mater un jour mais bon
d'abord faire autre chose genre
fractures commotion web écoute les
blanches ce n'est pas si mal sorti
l'un d'eux surtout maintenant qu'on
avait changé notre 15 mois c'est le
mental sur quasiment la broye aux rives
leurs réflexions jadis du gruyère un
gars de ce fils qui va écrire et
maintenant attention regret poitiers de
suisse y'a pas de trous dans le gruyère
emmental alors il m'a dit ah oui les
mental ça va oui donc enfin plus
d'erreurs fromage
ainsi on en fera d'autres mais pas
celle-là mg6 défendre le match j'aurais
dit cosim
c'est bizarre que s'est tourné fin ok
c'est pas qu'on ait pu choquer nord mais
j'ai pas par leur bon je n'étais pas
très fier mais pourquoi fait-on oui
comme les besoins de rester hyper fois
encore sur ses proches précieux la rs6
est ce qu il reste 15 minutes dans la
portion simple plus un ok moi c'est bien
sa démarche de trois heures ça va
relativement vite et est en route
question en fait c'est tout le temps des
matchs les jargons son huitième de
finale et après ça il n'y a pas de
tournoi de chez pas quoi phase de
groupes
un ballet tournoi ça a déjà été fait là
il ya combien de combien de joueurs je
crois que alors il me convient
1 cette fois trouvé 21 et oui phares de
l'accord donné par nada il avait perdu
contre bas contre euro ou chez ou chez
china elle avait perdu comme china ok
bon rien pour le se défend bon c'est un
peu chiant mais leur union trois n 5 ce
doit être un coup nîmes parce qu'on va
prendre du fou un mot sur yamaha
il vous prendre du plomb on se fait des
trous partout mais h4 bonnes attaches
cinq banques et 4ième et attend rien à
faire en fait qu'elle est donc une fois
ils ont souffert sur les huit thèmes
digitales et des fantômes d'amd vite ça
c'est pas de choix compliqués un ouais
voilà encore four n'a pas encore perdu
non
et à m'offrir actions chez quelqu'un
c'est pas moi ma connexion ça va aller
l'autre alors burly propose h si ce
point de htc qui adam profond on a
besoin de ceux qui ont acheté pour
sauver notre sujet si donc dès qu'il est
plus là ça va pas et c'est chiant fait
modem de jouer mais c'est le coût final
craquera parce que rappeur un pion et
puis à perdre de fouet puis plus rien ne
va ouais
donc on leur demande ce que tu as fait
hier un bon match et que chatter
beaucoup de passer par ce match que
plage explique j'ai gagné j'ai gagné sur
elle et plus de conviction est sur le
fil du rasoir en jeu gagnée ça se dit un
sais pas si je suis pas très forte et un
espace en france je pensais vraiment mon
gros point faible c'est l'expression
vilchez je suis pas né en france j'ai
donc de 0 à 9 ans j'étais en roumanie et
mon gros point faible c'est l'expression
des fois des fois j'invente des trucs et
je ressemble
ouais mais qui sont pas tout à fait ça
tu vois et des coups bas voir son petit
charme quand tu fais tu pour te faire
ton proche 5
en fait non oui bah était de quelqu'un
en roumanie
j'étais de iasi c'est le côté de la
moldavie
c'est dans l'est jamais leur manière est
donc bien l'occasion du coup tu es belle
passion commune b bat plus trop
heureusement j'ai ma mamie et qui vient
chez nous on régulièrement
du coup je pratique le roumain mais
ouais ça ressemble aux français un petit
peu pas plus que ça bah disons que ça
ressemblerait plus à l'espagnol à
l'italien qu'aux français parce qu'en
fait le français c'est très bizarre
c'est une langue latine mais finalement
toutes les terminaisons et tous les
trucs c'est pas du tout du tout le même
genre et des terminaisons les genres le
même souhait de tout le même son qui
peut s'écrire de 40 façon ça c'est
vraiment ça correspond pas trop aux
langues latines donc le français souffre
en particulier extrêmement dur à prendre
aussi bas salaires bizarre d'ailleurs on
s'est parlé on s'est plu
et en fait j'ai fait un peu de des teams
au logis dans mes études etc
le français est vraiment genre psycho
rigide comme langue on a vraiment du mal
à accepter les changements alors c'est
normal genre l'anglais en fait tu peux
inventer un mot et les mets qu'ils vont
dire ni qu'elle envoie le mettre dans le
dico alors le français
le français mais c'est pareil oui on est
beaucoup plus psychorigide en français
qu'en anglais par exemple
ouais non je crois moi je trouve que
c'est une belle langue française je sais
c'est joli mais si il ya un truc de
linguistes pareil c'est que en france l
accent tonique donc l'accent du mot
l'intonation du mot et des toujours
placé en dernière syllabe
c'est pas forcément super mélodieux par
exemple espagnol de rédaction chante en
anglais pareil pas français c'est
toujours sur la dernière syllabe
ouais moi c'est un style au lac et talc
et heureusement correspond pas à
l'anglais je me fais tu y es lang lang
j'aime bien mais j'ai toujours très
facile l'angle entre kg pas cessible
c'est plus facile c'est sûr que ça fasse
il a pu langue de toute façon c'est
l'allemand il n'y a pas de débat qui est
peut-être collombat si non la roumanie
était sous influence urss mais pas pas
trop mon patronyme commun à part à part
camarades temps oui thomas reisch s'est
levé - en roumain et en
ah et en résoudre très très drôle ça
vient de l'urss
sinon il ya un patron très soviétique
future bondit qu'au maniement des prix
et par cette partie portait si bien qu
elle est malheureusement mais c'est pour
ça que je dis ou chez elle a une
technique incroyable en fait parce que
dès qu'elle a l'avantagé va pas te
lâcher du tout elle mord quoi si le
pitbull elles craignent un coup de boule
de flipper je passe avec ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas eu de vrai
tournant entre guillemets quoi ce que tu
peux le nombre de plats typiques rouyn
d'ailleurs c'est quoi la cuisine sert
mal et c'est alors ces deux espèces des
rouleaux de printemps est généralement
j'ai fait avec des feuilles de vigne
mais ce peut être aussi avec des
feuilles de chou est donc en gros de
bain je met du rythme et humer désherbe
tu m'aider des poivrons quand tu mets
plein d'or d'une teinte d'aigus
généralement ça peut être aussi fier
avec de la viande me mais du coup je
suis moi non et
et voilà ça c'est pas le sien mal et
c'est bon ouais c'est très bien fait des
vignerons et plein de légumes
gt rien complet top 3 5 7
c'est jouable mais l'eau est là sur
quelle horreur jacquet dans ce parti
j'étais ok bah égalisation c'est déjà
c'était déjà pas mal partis avec leur
fausse et 3 et la paire dafoe qui
s'envolait mimer la gambie d'avocats et
donc on a le vrai candidat m'accepter g3
3e cat à la houle et non pas des qualifs
6 heures je pourrais vont faire tout
armé donc ouais balises de la catalane
c'est ce fonds g2 qui m'inquiète pas mal
à beaucoup par une femme de couleur à
verser quelque part mais revoir c'est là
veulent faire parler pour la regagner
plus tard je voulais faire c'était
correct
non mais bon wajam français quatre tours
d1 et mâcha de tête
cailleux 5,5 ou qu'ils aient prendre des
cas peut-être 5 ou aussi d'avoir donc
wet est vanina il préfère ça que d'avoir
fait des français 5 elle même avant et
d'échanger les dames c'est plus son
style quoi alors tu pouvais reprendre
sais pas pourquoi
après le truc c'est que sur dame prend
des quatre fous procès si tu te tires
foot 17
peut-être qu'on accomplit pas tellement
occupés moi je suis très matérialiste
sûrement même
racine des penas mon nom face à me
parler
l'argent c'est important mais ouais tu
aurais bien chez page orange aurait près
le puy un cas les prenez quatre mois
elle m'a pas du coup je comprends
qu'avec le fait cette soul tellement ça
en fait je sais un peu changé enfin j'ai
l'impression avec l'âge on évolue
beaucoup à christine normalement fou
ouais mais bon je me fais fier trois
fois moins que moi quoi manger cheveux
blancs qui arrivent et où bart et encore
des chevaux encore des cheveux mef l'on
s'attendait à voir que ça non mais on
les voit pas ils sont jugés par le
casser il suffit que je me qualifie si
franchement le cas ça fait quasiment une
perruque 1
et ouais ça va bien avec ferveur s'agit
d'un fort manque de tendance est
vraiment dommage que la corse a annulé
l'an prochain la saxe est peut-être le
temps je préfère at on encore besoin de
gérer
après tu préfèrerais peut-être encore
plus y aller et pas le jouer quoi est il
plus tard et piscines des jeux les blind
test baghla progrès l'apéro à moitié des
terrains comme un temps gelé ça il y
estime hugo qualifie à former pour
l'infime ouais donc quels tournois se
doit de porticcio en corse donc
porticcio à côté d'ajaccio
c'est un beau tour noire jusqu'à être
cool c'est quand le temps est fini
deux jours après il ya le mien traduite
dans les montagnes qui est très sympa à
txema match et voilà donc c'est un beau
tournoi une belle semaine ce cadre
idyllique n'ayons pas peur des mots et
et voilà donc du coup tu encore mieux si
tu es là je suppose de chaque jeu fait
que le tour a admis ci pourra te disent
tous les jours par exemple serait bien
de faire quelque chose en échange
non mais tu en es très sympa il est fort
il ya c'est bien mais en fait c'est
juste quand il fait 14 heures tu vois la
piscine bio maintenant tu es réfléchir
je les ai vues elles de bouffe début
ouais ça tu peux essayer à machad option
com content de rien franchement c'est
une bonne idée
bof je t'ai réquisition pour monstres et
mon jour une réponse comme ça c'était
défis et l'enjeu cdd bio se sache
d'ailleurs invité pour un petit joss à 6
voilà fond de crise et de ses passings
enfin bon c'est calme qui était presque
à may a des défauts point cette étroite
rue mais bon je sais pas j'ai pas top
confiant mais elle n'a pas fait
mais l'aide d'une aile pour les dames
c'est en salaires primes là peut-être ça
va c'est visuellement ça ne ferait que
mettre d'abord réseau la tour dans le
monde et à se faire ça t'as qu'a laissé
trois ans tu t'en sors tu t'en sors avec
sang-froid quoi alors match d'adoption
ça veut dire c'est si tu gagnes 10
parties de suite
ok tu vas me donné tes cheveux je garde
mais je fais je préfère jouer pour me
soucie c'est bien à cela je l'avais as
tu veux riches
je trouve ça équitable non mais on s'en
sort on s'en sort elle valide à quoi
défend l artac beaucoup plus de temps
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont elle est
là à celle interne est reparti à 5 + 1
encore cédé patron des ja est parti qui
durent longtemps va beaucoup trop c'est
beaucoup trop long mais c'est marrant
fait que ma perception du temps changent
et que les trucs sur internet c'est en
fait en général c'est quand on fait un
tournoi s'est départi qui dure six
heures quoi est normal en fait on trouve
même pas salon quand on joue là tu
regardes ça je dis [ __ ] c'est quoi les
démineurs aucun point ouais mais
peut-être que ça va le faire
ce que on va pas me faire des trous sur
la colonne des tourelles
allez lenclud un petit truc va pas le
pion à des noirs il y peu de chance on
va te cacher c'est un pion passé il ya
le père de fouilles des trucs à
l'épreuve en prendre cette voie ça c'est
bien
tête de la tourtelle pas pourquoi on
attend oui oui mais je te passe mieux 5e
un problème en animé assez sûrement
pensé -213 sa manière comme beaucoup
moins que ça me faisait peur je sais pas
oui pour recul ya littéralement tout
emprise tient sa reprise
on comprend dès 8 n'attend qu'à rallier
pointe à un prince est on là haut c'est
relou serono va faire le tour des deux
d'accord willaey 5 à la saq
multi-menaces peut-être calice châtenois
tôt et ça marche ça marche ça marche
bon faut sortir tous ces cloisons voilà
alors je peux voir et d en face du fou
il ya 13 secondes en face c'est pas mal
je crois qu'il est le plus dur j'ai
sorti du pire aller et là c'est le
moment de ce quiz a310 couiza que ces
trois attaques soit au top mais les
problèmes sur f2 d'accord comme ça tu
pouvais bouger scabal quoi ça s'il bouge
ce que en f3 non mais ça n'empêche pas
que l'on est actuellement même ça oui
voilà avait que 3 tu le
tu leur donnes des jambes quoi couvrir
il peut rebondir et faire des trucs c4
j'aime pas trop
et moi je pense qu'il avait pas macho
mais là il va perdre son chien chien on
est moins bien et ancien fief de bouger
la dame là
merci le petit rêve je connais ce pseudo
c'est bien me dire juste salut fab bon à
ce que ben à 7 secondes
cette seconde avec le petit rajout je
sais pas c'est chaud il ya mes fans qui
achètent la communauté arrive elle
valide à feignies un pied lâche 4 au bon
moment qu'on repart seniors i love floor
est parti ouais ça dérange pas
d'échanger les 9,4 au final est assez
simple pour les noirs avec le pion passé
abonde en parlait depuis longtemps ça il
avance un puits s'est il faut compte qui
est d'allier machin qu'ailleurs but pour
la là bas ils bougent pas et techniques
domination et des regrets fish a fait
gagner du temps ça ça sera pour régner à
cela parce que tu ne sais plus nuls elle
va perdre c'est dommage
ouais demain jockey elle a paniqué et la
panique ina
vanina et la panique et c'est fini elle
devrait convertir c'est assez facilement
voix c'est choquant rien niveaux
atteints c'est quand même tendu tendu un
bon je sais pas si ses limites en vrai
je trouve qu'il joue elle joue vraiment
vraiment bien mais avec une seconde a
répondu tout seul épisode
ouais du coup sauvage bon après c'est à
dire que l'état marque pas mais athée
cette partie ouais quand tu reviens tu
as juste envie de hockey donc chez china
hyway des projets lean qui du coup prend
le voilà c'était la dernière partie
hockey du coup ça dure trois minutes 3 +
1 s'était fait une petite pause
ouais petite pause pour cinq minutes
mais voyez coûte au moins le match et
plus secs fed avant et je sais pas je me
sens voleurs de nager plus vite quoi
jouer j'ai largement plus vite avec la
cadence qui ce raccourci mais peut-être
ouch et plus précises niveau technique
j'ai un peu sur ma propre style
mais c'était pareil dans le dans le
match dans le match qu'ils ont eu avant
sauf que en fait où j'étais quand même
beaucoup plus elle a empêché de jouer en
fait l empêcher de jouer son style son
style comme crosby avec du livre qui
suivent il faut qu'elle envoie quoique
sert de ce premier match pour optical
envoie tout mon style est peut-être
ouais mais les lots sont très très
proches en tout cas je pense que c'est
un match assez équilibré un peu moins
déséquilibrée que sa vie d'avant en tout
cas acheter j'étais surprise puisque ça
que tu sors dans le monde joue pas mal
d'embûches mais bon après on recense
arrive aussi ouais ce qui était dommage
c'est qu'elles avaient elles avaient pas
mal d'opportunités surtout dans la
première partie puis après j'ai
l'impression que c'est laisser couler
quoi ces problèmes quand tu concept mal
dans le cours du match
je sais que tu vas pas gagner là-bas jeu
jusqu'au bout c'est déjà être motivés à
fond donc voir ce qui va mettre ça vient
de gagner directe celle là en fait
chaque fois on redémarre l'espace ont
volé
je regarde si par hasard j'ai pas le
lien
tu diras ouais bon aujourd'hui on a fait
sur la vidéo mais la prochaine fois on
veut je veux bien être dans la cour vaut
donc voilà bon c'est nickel mais je me
sens je me sens un peu mieux après le
petit café ça c'est de la zone message
le café ça fait rien elle laisse aux ja
non je suis pas sûr ça va être très
compliqué pour bonne humeur maintenant
il m'a l'air plus enfants que dans leur
match d'avant goût de moi j'ai pas vu je
serai pas l'historique du couchois trop
bas trop m'avancer pronostics
moi je dis pronostics vanina gagne 8 7
avec bien but en or à la fin il ya 7 7
et dernière partie de folie non c'est
bon un café ça suffit ça dépend le
dosage
vous passez les cartes d'or la table et
tu fais les cafés à l'ancienne dans la
cafetière italienne presto what else
j'te parle je sais pas faire c'est des
trucs way s'est détachée vous tu m'aimes
tu me trucs dedans tu appuies sur bouton
et ça tient caf poule compliquée du coup
et moi ce que je pense du match et j'en
sais rien en fait je suis plus pour les
antilles là parce que je le connais un
peu en réel j'aime bien mais sinon sur
ce que j'ai fait de première âgé un
centre que chez nina était un peu au
dessus mais justement comme eux de jouer
très vite unis n'a peut-être que c'est
parce que vous savez rien dire des fois
quand on fait juste l'autre elle s'est
adaptée clairement sa vitesse à la
cadence ça serait juste signe des
élections douteuses mais sinon c'est
juste elle est un peu endormie
ça peut aussi être être un problème
d'emploi semble dur de vraiment être
clair mais bon évidemment du sushi n'a
vu qu'elle mène 2 1 et c'était mieux
devant que derrière au score parce que
je disais sur ce je vais aller ya un
truc que j'ai oublié de faire battre les
cartes
non je voulais host depuis ma chaîne
j'ai oublié ce que le lait de soja est
autorisée s'est construit comme un
dopant là je pense à dopants de pain là
les noisettes et c'est cette fois plus
cher j'adhère à voir j'ai je prends des
produits de luxe mais des produits
moyens quoi luxe intermédiaire du duc
c'est qu'on puisse les à la menthe
personne n'importe quoi c'est pas est un
les demandes mais c'est quoi c'est pas
du jus de vente non le lait à la menthe
séduit c'est un peu comme euros d'amendé
et moi je prends des lots seuls les
fraises sirop de menthe hachée pas sûr
non c'était pas mon favori le voici en
photo alors du coup et pastis à la
fraise ou à la menthe un saab ont déjà
on parle de façon sérieuse quoi ok les
deux sont intéressants le pire au cas
c'est pas mal
et sinon sinon à la grenade ils savent
aussi ça dépend
alternez quoi ou les deux
rien dans chaque main et là encore c'est
juste un mois je pense que c'est un peu
la boisson thème de la semaine
je vois la pétanque au la belote c'est
bien s'adapter
à certains moments ça les élections
immédiates quoi aller de marbre de
l'ordre trouvent un truc en d'un chèque
doivent participent aux pieds ces trois
bons noms je croise juste b6 temps entre
normalement cavale en direct pourquoi
pas sûr c'est un peu bordélique je sais
pas trop ce qui se passe non mais bon
allez plus être des changes des dames
bref du g5 bon je le fous voilà impose
son style quoi présente toi voilà pagani
chez les catalans
mais du coup une sorte de petite finale
bon et non pas la paire de fumay peut
soit hyper bloqué donc les tv sont pas
si mal j'apprends à dessin tu prends là
j'aime pas trop prendre la direccte
cépages aurait gardé le dessin que je
pouvais le faire
ouais moi j'avais peur de cavale et c4
en fait voilà plaît pas du coup
peut-être au 7 ou des coups comme ça de
on essaie de tenir un peu des 5 ce qui
m'énerve c'est pour le fossé vite je
peux confère et puis jenson je tique sa
structure évoqué ses cascades et si
catégorique je peux pas faire faut
baisser parce que tu prends quand même
marche est donc tombé six aussi oui je
sais pas ban a du coup tu t'attendais tu
organises web on va le faire mais quatre
des cinq quoi je peux le faire
directement
notre grand roque ouais
bon rock tu as tué une mouche là non
pour une porte qui le tour les mouches
je suis assez rapide
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup plus que ça
ouais mec ou du coup la position je sais
pas trop je passais plein de trucs non
cavaillon ça serait plus on préfère un
petit peu les blancs ouais bon rien de
rien d'alarmant plus lourd les pions et
quoi wave 4 j'aime bien j'aime bien
jouer jouer jouer agressif quand même là
vanina tombé d'un web bon elle veut et
tébessa vraiment j'étais dans un trou de
toute façon tu vas faire absent quinze
jours ce que tu as honte et plus encore
ils solidifier les fendre les trucs en
fait bien le courage 5 f 5,6 et
puissance 4 c'est génial on va notre
rigueur en avoir raté cinq est bon les
records d'opportunités ursch mc rôle où
la puissance et sa taille a gagné 5 qui
va arriver tôt ou tard sa tournée c'est
chiant je demande le titre de ton et
d'études la qualité du bien celui
là il n'ya pas titre un titre
brilliant ch 118 de chaque brillante ok
mais c'est un petit truc il est tout
petit mais sévriens voilà le joli truc
pour l'aspect hockey il donc si on prend
un espion le truc c'est que y'a quoi on
regagne 1 sur 17 et de kelly revient aux
on récupère le pion il aura thème tourer
va devoir échanger 3,05 après vente se
fera dès 4 ans activé mais c'est déjà
pas super fun mais mais c'est chiant pas
là du coup mais bon c'est mieux de
prendre chez 4 je pense à la raison si
elle gagne vraiment actions et donc
c'est pas le bon scénario mais il faut
qu'elle lui trouve une variante plus
pêchus quoi dans les systèmes demande
pas 40 dans son jeu comme ça c'est
étonnant je suis pas d'ouverture j'ai du
mal à capter durant le match d'avant en
fait tu vois que ça se passe mal voulu
changer complètement quoi tu veux pas te
laisser deviner tout un match entier sur
le même sujet blanc faut dire même même
les souvent rien etc
orbea pire tu vois tu fais des six sous
sinon mayer battle of cape de quatre des
six mois c'est autre chose on va te
faire e 4 peut-être était-ce ait eu
tente peut-être qu'elle est super à
l'aise aussi et qui veulent se passe
partout et a perdu mais fait face au oui
non mais tant pis plus fort mais
lepage juge dans sa filiale et sur ce
match et chaque fois il faut changer un
truc là la saison prochaine je vais
jouer pour mulhouse pata points
à mulhouse comme ça ouais ben normal
sans cesse il mais je suis encore elle
n'est pas vraiment disponible pour jouer
aux échecs habite toujours en georgie
watts
selon porsche de paillis marie tu as dit
le club mais pas la ville c'est qu'une
demi réponses alors que t'habites pas à
mulhouse
je regarde j'ai vu un enfant dit gérard
déménager avant j'habitais dans un
procès déjà déménagé très récemment près
plus proche de chez mes pains giannakou
non je bouge tout le temps je pense que
si c'est la rate et s'inquiétait cadeaux
et peut-être ans qu'elle y un joueur
aussi bon bah écoute nul sentir très
très bien et du coup fourier fourvoyé
faut pas faiblir
c'est bien c'est bien peur pris le break
j'ai une proposition d'un club anglais
c'est quoi la boutique le rookie je vais
jouer le tournoi de noël de la pomme et
23 parmi elles il entendre
ouais je sais pas trop ce qu'elles sont
en train de jouer à priori j'aime bien
et noir sur patate
ouais mais c'est une ouverture chaude je
trouve ça peut convenir à vanina quoi
aller à l'étranger cette pièce à l'est
de deir me reprendre g7 n'arriva et ses
5 après un truc comme ça mais deux dames
subitement près normalement à ce plan
tant les deux hommes sont chics et sont
là ont déjà fait une force et une partie
avec deux des meilleurs de chic et
chacun contre contre stéphane servi de
clichy est et c'est une partie très très
marrante
c'est chaud à deux cordes et deux dames
totalement pas l'habitude de faire et en
fait j'ai gagné parce que j'avais jamais
l'initiative et je sais qu'un film
d'anne formaté du coup vu que j'en avais
une deuxième balle j'ai sorti la
deuxième c'est beau moi j'ai eu un truc
bizarre j'ai deux dames brassard n'est
sûrement qu'une ou 0 d'ailleurs je sais
pas mais il a les pièces le cop 16 et je
sais que c'est une française le parti du
chef local d'une catherine 5,6 par an il
ya très longtemps
même si du coup et d'altitude amis qui
donne peut-être pas des quatre bras je
rends tu es content de le donner si tu
bouffes le foot creusement active ces
deux bons mois de prendre ces quatre
mais ouais ouais ouais ouais mais
vraiment rien changer les habitudes
merdad choc non ça suffit quoi on va
trouver là georges meyer au criminel
quoi c'est vrai qu'elle a un style très
très technique
là où chez china bon allez vous gagnez
une fois parce technique les piaules
ouverture f 6 vous en pensez quoi
c'est une ouverture pense que trop bien
poser question c'est vrai le pion f6
notre propre à sa fin quand tu donnes
que que la case en fait c'est un pion
quand on dit pendant que 4 c'est le pion
qui vend le 4 est bon le pion qui arrive
si c'est jamais bon temps pourri parce
que tous voulaient diagonale vers 3d
génial blanche pour la dame pour le fou
et une fois la casse pour coup cavaliers
ok mais après si tu parles de cavalli m6
c'est peut-être ça la vraie question
elle a fait travailler quoi baoulé qui
est exactement mais c'est comme ça du
coup là c'est jouable surtout qu'ils ont
tous les deux pions n'ont jamais tout
interdit en fait dessus et c'est
qu'avant comme dirait fans belges
coincés du caddie n'ai jamais bougé le
pion ouais voilà près le truc c'est que
les échecs c'est bien en direct comme ça
après plus t'avances plus tu peux les
enfreindre et tu sais à peu près quand
tu peut enfreindre les règles au début
chaud le truc avec toi même parce que ce
sera bon neuf fois sur dix de suivre ça
bah tu joueras le bon coup neuf fois sur
dix il est tant pis la fois où il aurait
fallu le faire
j'étais exception tu peux faire des
échecs statistiques ce temps guy hoquet
voilà c'est ça la cigale salaire assez
ennuyeux et un moyen mais comment tu
tactile chinois wahaha fond c'est
peut-être 5
j'ai pas trop tu bouges des pièces quoi
et je vois pas de plan miracle mais en
fait juste jouer vite c'est bien trouvé
le fond des 5 1 les cinq maintenant que
cette casse s'est libéré d'afat voyages
obtenu à tours où un monde bien pourquoi
pas tu défends bien champions et puis
voilà on y va ok ouvert à reprendre
cette j'imagine prendre un set je vais
passer parfois énormes
moi je pense que pour ça que ce job
aussi cela fait quatre ans c'est donc
durer un peu le flou adverse à défendre
cinq coups de feu ça c'est des fois
qu'il est trop long et bien ça c'est
fait
la foulée 5 c'est bien mais mon iphone
je crois qu'elle est mieux ma voix pour
empêcher la rentrée sur leur seconde
mais c'est peut-être pas si grave c'est
moi autour du foot si ce temps ses huit
noms samara gagnant ouais j'aime bien
alors seulement engrangé cette même voie
mais bon c'est chiant c'est pas tout
simple leur fuite au quai pas mal non
plus et je vous sais pas mal trop bref
[Musique]
sajjil-2 sa fiche pas mal
pas grand chose mais être cinq points
aime toujours gmail 5 complètement six
tours s'est vite et si elle prend je
vais faire fouiller 4 est aussi sans fin
dans leur bus tu veux mais m6 d'autres
justice ouais moi même prise un sens ok
marielle à l'éolien allez hop on est
reparti là et donc ils restent et
resteront bien alors je tire c'est peut
être la dernière déjà
c'est peut-être la dernière je vais dire
combien de temps il reste non non non
non non il reste 15 minutes entre +1
vous allez vers d'autres puissances
oui oui tu voulais déjà avec bull est
déjà super chaud mon record une nouvelle
variante système de londres mais une hot
line
mais d'autres joueurs dont un peu le
système de leurs actes et blanc je vais
je touche pas sa journée
non c'était sur des gangs vidame
non moi c'est comme au mieux le jour ses
4,4 fin sur un cinquième coup ouais non
mais bon tu seras une pression qui va
ressembler un peu notre carte française
suivant en les blancs au jeu mais son
projet pour la décision si vite ok pour
isoler sol est intéressant c'est
d'amener 5 et un peu chelou mais des
quatre ok prendre l'espace un peu gênant
pour peut-être le pion c'est d'un jour
je vous pose une question qui est ces
trois ans la loi échanger et peut-être
deux fois 6
oui et peut-être faire g61 jours ci a
besoin
non c'est pas mal ça
et oui je veux jouer quatre sur la
graine sahel dont sa balance ça
balançait prépare je voulais tout
cavalier ff4 détour c'est un atout c'est
sa vie quand j'ai dû travailler c'est un
ordre de coin un peu spécial j'ai
retravaillé cette ligne récemment et que
j'aime cachez vous ne jouez pas les
bleus de faire entendre ils rêvent au
point dessus la g fait le s'est troué
alors jouer autre chose
fabien quand vous préparez un look au
prochain grand prix là mais je crois
qu'il est déjà très potes non moi je
suis au taquet un bon le truc c'est
qu'évidemment on pouvait reprendre deux
fois parce qu'il ya ce petit fourche et
échec
ouais bon bout en bout de poids ouais on
est au top top top schéma mellacois
cavaliers g4 ou un truc comme ça au jeu
bouchra quoi jouent-ils bouffe ne voir
que des quatre dom baissa pas le prendre
on va voir cette dame décide
wen v6 a offert 60 m en soit tous ravis
de s'éviter ces cinq s'activer ça a pas
l'air bof le président et nous passons
il ya beaucoup de plus de potentiel
attaque côté blanc ça serait pour faire
de même trois peut-être un peu chiant et
trois coups bas fausse libérer un moment
je sais pas individuelle quand il fut
proche 6 qui rôdent quoi
[Musique]
mais c'est faux 5 c'est la grèce on voit
l'ambulance se place bien chaque coup
une petite menace est la meilleure voie
phocéen question bras de fer assistons
qui est fier de ce que j'ai vite et on
tient comme on va faire défoncer pour
que plus lisse et zhu pets cool d'angers
3 je crois que ces femmes mais enfin je
dis ça à l'air finit alors tu peux rien
faire tu étais encore fc saviez
peut-être quand même d'un proche si wade
il faut faire puis j'espère que les gens
seront prêts puis ils sont pas trompés
souligne m
ouais faut compter 6 à détroit web on
s'est pas mal 1.536 et d'emprunt c'est
fini
voir qu'il faut qu'on calcule ce petit
jeu dire salaire symbolique et objets 6
en fait parce que enfin tout va mais
surtout bon on a pu avoir pour être
trois à ou la bastille s'échanger des
multiples la même mais bon le fer forgé
5 tab sacrifie la dame au on s'est super
bien vu non pourquoi pourquoi pas
j'aurais près d'une entorse
bon c'est pas ma tête et je crois que
j'ai cité plus incroyable incroyable on
va falloir gagner maintenant
allez on y va annoncer ce que c'est quoi
ça ouais tour à ces dommages là était
bien revenu ouais ouais c'est dommage de
brocchi support de nos surprises
on n'y croit plus matières rares je
tiens la torture et le chic bar mais la
truite est magique et l'autre qui se
fait prendre exactement sur la même case
à la tour de vis et passe à coeur car
est toujours de ce délit
bon après c'est dans la clé blague est
reparti mais mes entrailles du beau jeu
ça c'est clair il ya du beau jeu
je vais regarder il reste combien de
temps sur wade doit rester à les 9
minutes
sept minutes bon sur mon dos partira pas
cette cadence en tout cas j'aime
beaucoup ce maintien franchement ya des
spectacles
ouais puis moi ce serait avec un point
d'écart et doris pendant les parties
donc ce fun pas illégal d'un chat pièces
comme ils disent qu'ils ont des
fractures de la rétine au café voilà les
faits une toile a fait une tour sur
talent de une tour on va pas dire super
bien joué mais avant c'était sympa la
partie franchement c'était une belle
partie et je trouve que techniquement il
est impressionnante
auch et non pas mal pas l'air facile à
manoeuvrer avec sa page facebook le
savez j'ai changé j'ai l'impression
ouais c'est donc ouais j'aime bien prévu
at a envie de garder pied c'est sûr
parce que tu as telle initiative est
donc tu envie de garder un max de paix
sur l'échiquier mois ouais ouais les
pièces ne pas se marcher dessus lucas et
b4 qui est un peu loin
il serait bien si tu enlèves 500 québec
à nice au top il attaquerait des quatre
couvrira la diagonale est donc cette
plate a peut-être des chances d'attaquer
les blancs bon à voir comment s'est fait
ce simple mais des trafics à 13,5 voit
pas souvent repris 4 f 5 ans je vais pas
tourner non mais t'es chiant quoi
d'échangés mais c'est vrai que au cinéma
dans chaque partie elle veut soit
échangé dame soit échangé en masse j'ai
l'impression qu'elle
vraiment bien son son type de jeu quoi
mais c'est bien joué pour le canada le 5
très chiante équipe 4 qui menacent donc
tu as un problème sur j'ai deux très
claire et forte quelque chose assez
rapidement 4 ok peut-être web ou qu'elle
va le voir partir un peu de liens ou
d'un match quatre jours
oui oh oui mais tu en rêves trois prises
froid de f5
c'est quelqu'un de bien je les veux
home talent et il faudra quand même
c'est pas si simple qu'elle préfère
payer 17 mais bon ce roi est vraiment
j'aime pas trop pour l'instant
oui d'options principaux studios
nouvelle structure bête type la colonne
est entrepreneur et 625
c'est ce temps vont s'activer crible à 1
sinon t'as pas de compensation pour le
pion ouais ouais donc ans est clairement
c'est potentiellement un courrier 17
aussi tu pas puisqu'elle a préféré c'est
sûrement assez de couacs dans ses sets
ça paraît logique
ces sept fous des cinq ans présent au
dessous des 5 quand même façon on va y
venir
voilà qu'à valider si tu vas finir pas
voir
récupérer cela se finisse pas fini
normalement on écoute ses organes son
pion on sait pas absents fait même si
deschamps à papier contre le chou n'y a
qu'un pas l'option sur casse blanche au
centre fans ghazi un jour du devoir il a
quoi ok la passion des 5 il est reparti
ses adieux pyongyang de prendre des 5e
para marque qui est des trois peut-être
les trois cas les d'être raciste course
à la mana qui était qu'il y ait des
trains pardon enfin je veux dire non
mais en même temps enfin te papa deux
états d'abord ouais mais bon ça c'est
déjà rare pas le faire tout seul m
lequel ans et 55 miles un sommet
d'autres l'euro montait à 4 5 pas
prendre ce faux parce qu'elle a l'air
assez il n'a pas trop d'avenir quoi il
s'est inscrit à pôle emploi mais pas de
propositions boulot pour l'instant mais
s'est blessé au bras un pion un pion
lequel attaqué aussi s'attaquer est pas
grave de ne pas de tour cette fois ci
phobie 3 pts ok faut pas gagné 46
secondes
ces boues qui ont pas tort f4 du koweit
rush katia hockey va trouver tout ça
elle va trouver quoi faire tomber le
food de tours son 7e côté c'est pas si
évident sa part a gagné un petit
territoire s accroche c'est là notre
plan qui est bien c'est juste monté
droit viage 4g 5 et vous gagnez vite
tête faut pas se précipiter
non tu peux apprendre parce qu'il ya
tour j'ai prise tour battant 7.5 ouais
ok c'est sympa
ouais bah écoute elle s'accroche et ken
plutôt dominé je trouve dans le match
mais elle lâche pas de bac
il apporte tout accroché des fois ça
peut finir en soit il reste six secondes
dans la portion entre appréciable c'est
la dernière partie de la 3 + 1 en fait
on voit le rock le buzzer à partie puis
annulée allez hop c'est bien grandes
lignes benoît j'avais 6 ans chez ardam 7
ouais c'est jouable mais il ya bien sûr
que oui j'ai dix-sept kelly prend font
face ne pas prendre du fou tu prends de
la dame ça va
le 4 4 6 ok et c'est quoi ce faussaire
d'études ou kenseth et tu rendras cette
espèce de française bon il a pris la
même structure près partie d'avant
j'aime pas je pense qu'elle est conique
la maman bien que je pense que gunino
chlore connecte à un moment bien que
l'auteur ou chi minh à ces schémas que
moi donc moi je serais peut-être pas
rentrer là dedans mais bon après c'est
lé à court d'idées de quoi faire comme
tout le système
voilà le tout prend ok c'est bien pour
l'un de ses clients spécialiste du
système de long dans le chat noir et
blanc et je pense qu'ils adorent voir le
vent rock
non mais c'est dur avec la colonne est
ouverte
et si vous pouvez le faire soit étape
mais mais bon ils coûteront avoir déjà
de me casser une tombola
c'est légère baisse il faut des trois
camps échangent déjà hyper heureux de
racheter 5 et du coup on force peut-être
bien fou des 3 1 parce que là vu que on
attaque la dame celle où je bouffe la
tour et donc sur damas quatre f5 on
rattaque adam
mais alors il faut les trois saveurs et
en échange on fera tourner vite on a
même des gens se ruent gaynor à ce point
non mais je prends double x64 taku mais
en fait la position ça peut tourner dans
les deux sens sur ces majorités bande
majorité
17h05 et 5e 4 d'avancé mais là bon du
coup c'est pas du tout aussi simple que
ça il ya beaucoup de montreuil chic et
surtout cases blanches bon à travers cet
acte j'aime bien
mckenna finalement
pacifica liège 3 7 euros 4,5 un jour
cinq mois la d2 quelqu'un que j'aime
bien qu'à son va tout mais ça serait il
avait bien trop tard et prendre la
colonne c'est clair ça peut être assez
utile sinon tu peux tenter aussi tu veux
garder at war avec pendant un moment de
faire à 5 à 4 j'appelle tous les blancs
fait c'est pas une vraie structure
pourrait menacer les prix ont doublé
mais ils sont cool parce que pas très
bon en fait et même il peut être très
chiant que tu peux les avancées ça te
fait du monde à l'attaqué avant de passe
ici un cadre aux horribles à des
problèmes en france elle organise au
delà du coup je sais pas louper tmg six
tours 8
le jouer vite en plus de mettre la
pression à fond peuvent être horrible ok
bapt est pas choisi peut-être première
fête du match qu'elle est comme est de
moins bien c'est bien dans les minutes
avancent en plus faut juste pas quel
jour trop vite une connerie quoi ça sert
d'être mauvais que prévu 4 vous prendra
25 au joli ça sera facile quoi yes a lui
même d'objets 400 marchands qui vendent
à mes gars de même plus précise julie
aller au bal à baden
[Musique]
les besoins que cet essai cependant une
pièce est beau recettes ou quoi ok
wallace votre site je vous écris blanc
mais bon à cinq je serai bien joué
histoire de même fossé 6 pour empêcher
tour des 7 je vais super safe quoi à 5
sécurisé celui-là
voilà le temps de finir il va nous
trouver ça le jeu à sa main et du coup
ils passeraient devant quoi bon en fait
elle a guidé à partir ses finances et
parfois du match mais la première c'est
la conduit de fait à quoi bon achat 5
ok on s'arrangeait ok bon bon de prendre
nickel ni kane et du coup et passe en
tête juste avant le but l'attaquant
justin mobylette c'est bon signe a
débusqué rothen là ça va être ça va être
un plus si elle n'a pas encore joué
quatre dance machine semble
vanina non ça qu'elle sait faire un
message pendant la pause parce que j'ai
joué au tennis après c'est pas tout à
fait wm women in ternational absolument
pas ce que tu penses que quelle fille
reprend des déchets qui seraient émis au
gym question que je sais pas je suis pas
pour donner mes trucs normalement il a
il a un bon duo de la bon duo de choc et
ça se voit dans les skis fait après les
lignes les tournois c'est quand même
c'est un investissement émotionnel en
temps plein de trucs et chez chiron
après il ya dans le niveau intrinsèque
qui a pas de raison qu'il ne fasse pas
mais mais après c'est énorme estime m et
voilà les parties c'est à dire six
heures on a une par jour pour les
ouvertures ça a énormément changé
tu peux pas jouer toujours trouvé le
truc il faut travailler à fond et donc
voilà donc après 6,6 à l'intérêt cki qui
donne à fond il est pas de raison qu'ils
fassent pas mais déjà je pense pas qu'il
va tenter de faire je pense qu'elle la
compétition intéressant fait non il aime
bien développés il a très très bien
développé et mis à part avec les gens le
stream excellent il a touché toute une
frange de la population qui serait
peut-être jamais intéressé aux échecs
et puis tous les trucs sur un tati le
fait très bien
après peut-être ya les tourrades bits
vers chez lui je pense qu'ils pourraient
pour les participants il n'y a pas de
raison mais de partir faire des tournois
tu pars quinze jours chez toi
machin c'est pas facile en fait c'est la
vie c'est comme quand sort c'est très
long très long
c'est chaud si je dois gérer leur
cotation aussi parce que fait cette
terrible de honte a fait une super
partie tu as bien joué six heures tu
fais une courrier à la fin et que tu
finis mes repères car nul une victoire
très méritée c'est une possibilité aussi
à ses désirs tout un autre genre par
matières entrant prendre c'est vrai on
après peut-être qu'un jour ils
changeront tout ça que tu auras des
trucs à 15 plus rapide façons la can en
salaire de plus moi s'accélère il ya une
cadence je trouvais intermédiaire pas
mal c'était une heure et demie pour la
partie et les 30 secondes par coup là
que dans ce qui est en pleine tournée en
espagne
ça fait quatre heures de jeu maximum
on sait déjà longue mais en fait ça va
point de partir c'est pourquoi je
n'importe quoi et tu peux me faire de
rhône par jour donc du coup les toits de
cinq jours ça va je vais sur ce forum en
espagne jo j'ai fait pas mal d'années
web en général de savi des échecs 6
enfin des tournois cm un signalement
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est
quasiment pas possible réalisable
financièrement il faut être vraiment
fort mais enfin je veux dire top 100
mondial quoi encore comptez 100e
mondiale n'est pas large mais ouais cité
top 20 mondial qui vit très bien
donc tous les autres il faut faire des
trucs autour en fait soit jeux pour
s'amuser avoir un métier à côté soit
sinon voilà donner des cours faire des
commentaires faire avant tout le truc
que je fais dans les dvd réalisé des
stages et des cours ils faire des livres
faire des articles
voilà après tu te débrouilles quoi mais
il faut aussi accepter une vie où t'as
pas de sécurité n'étaient pas t'as pas
de ces listes est toujours indépendant
donc c'est toujours se bouger
l'écran est flou moi je vois bien
partage web après même en général c'est
à c'est un bon niveau c'était j'aime les
gens ils vont tendance à faire confiance
au titre et pas forcément vers même
s'était pas non plus forcément un
excellent pédagogue les gens il vanta
mince affaire
les choses se sont ça c'est clair
quelqu'un qui grand maître normalement
ils censés savoir jouer mais on a fait
le truc c'est que tu as des gens qui
font ça à reculons les cours ils fonçage
de deux manières finances je le sens si
tu veut s'en faut c'est quand même un
métier à part entière et ça ça prend
petit à petit aussi te prépares tu
écoutes les trucs tu sais ce qui était
bien passée par femme voilà mais non
maître joueur procès chauwel clichy je
ne vends pas du rêve je conseille pas
vraiment des mesures prendre je passais
par là quoi c'est une vie c'est marrant
tu voyages qui fait des trucs cool mais
en fait tu peux faire des études et
faire ton truc à côté et quand même
arrière un titre aux échecs et les
cartes sont en vacances invités c'est je
pense c'est sa choré c'est de faire
comment les statuts jamie sont attribués
bassée il ya deux trucs faut avoir foi
voire le vélo minimum de 2500 donc il
faut affronter son classement il faut
faire trois normes
c'est à dire que dans trois tournois
différents dans ta vie faut avoir on va
dire fermer des pelles performance a
rabattu tout grand maître etc et site à
accumuler tout c'est tous ces trucs donc
tu as bien des tons classement tafer les
perdants ta vie tu peux y arriver
c'est quand même très très compliqué et
c'est un grand investissement par
finalement les grand mottois c'est le
formulaire non mais après c'est pareil
dans plein de sports individuels
ces données c'est le lot serre que même
au tennis c'était 3 100e mondiale thé
hyper fort mais en fait tu es nulle part
car plus personne dans la dette et match
tu vas pas les jouer les gros tournois
tu va galérer donc tu vas te battre à
fond pour essayer de contrer un tableau
final de faire des rimes boldon d'erreur
garros ou quoi soit pas tous bien coach
dans un club où tu fais autre chose
c'est-à-dire en fait mais dans l'espoir
de ne pas être juste bon moyen alors
sport co tu peux pas ce que tu vas jouer
peut-être avoir des visions qui joue le
maintien
tu vois jaro foot c'était un défenseur
pas trop mauvais tu vas te retrouver un
club pour je faisais j'avoue tennis ou
quoi en fait non c'est individuel faut
être vraiment bon sinon tu es considéré
comme nul
non mais laissez le faire mais c'est la
loi
c'est très concurrentiel et c'est comme
ça et cette portion de boulettes
dernière dernière portion du match
cela vous trouvez joué et jouent très
très vite goût nina c'est la colline des
ouais mais les milieux je trouve ouais
pour finir enfin puisque maintenant on
finira se développer j'avais pas trop
vite qu'ils le fassent donc d'être
callas 5 tu vas peut les embêter
jega à des petites idées et je trouve
très vite en tout cas je pense que c'est
une bonne stratégie
je vais vite et bien mal en charge et 4
je pense qu'étant des cistes pourquoi il
ya peut-être qui est des cinq attention
au gateway c'est s'est pris une peau de
banane c'est pas foutu pour autant fait
échec
je voudrais en trop vite en fait c'est
bien mais on regarde le moment d'arrêter
la défense c'est au tour quel dommage
peu trop vite
est apte et un tour à bayard j'apprends
de cavale et tu as vraiment une option
mais bon a peut-être que vient sa sueur
d'ailleurs avez peut-être le tour d'être
aussi qu'il faisait mal mais en fait
mais des pions serait de zèbres j'ai
vraiment pas confiance pour pour les
blancs dans ce jeu fun partie d'échecs à
4 fois je veux bien que ces quatre papa
lé là je vous dis je vais jouer au
tennis après je serai apte à cette
affaire mais mais non jusqu'à 4 j'aime
bien bon pour faire à l'occasion par ce
matin même équipe way you lie bat je
viens de ces quatre fait exprès non son
terme naturel et c'est peut-être un
accablant j'ai l'impression que le roi
c'est parce qu'il fout là quoi je me
revois tout blanc ni les nuls à bah oui
pas le choix bon bah bien avoir fait du
la mefou quel poste gardent de parler
trop vite ça peu symptomatiques ce que
la force et la joie toute blinde bien et
moins bien
non mais sinon les titres en général que
ce soit j'aime
même les titres féminins tu mets tu mets
lantin les avoir mais ouais tu peux
faire inviter
mais bon au final tu divises ça sert à
quoi
genre tu peux ne change pas sa place des
questions mais pas très bon en avant
parce que les questions de partout dans
la ville note très heureux quand ça
arrive juste après avec le recul si tu
t'habitues au truc tu t'es dit web ont
fait ouais j'ai 4 bon ben on est super
avec les landes en fait ça très grand
chose quand tu es juste contente
objectif c'est peut-être un peu comme un
diplôme après des années d'études bon
diplôme quoi moi j'ai une wii noire mais
cette histoire de même des invitations
aux échecs c'est même pas clair c'est
aussi bien ses avantages mais je suis
très heureux gfr mini tournoi je suis
invité ça me fait pas trop dépenser
d'argent c'est très bien mais au final
peut-être ce serait mieux qu'ils aient
plus d'un vite +2 pris de rides pendra
et que du coup en fait tu serais fort
dans des tournois locaux allégeance
ramènerait pas du goût de la terre sans
raison quoi
et qu'en fait ça serait mieux localement
pour les jours tu fais peut-être moins
de tournois mais tu as plus de chances
de gagner ce que tu fais vers chez toi
ici mais qui bien c'est finalement tu
peux pas l'intérêt de venir à toi tant
mieux même sa relève le tournoi mais il
n'y a pas de raisons de bien traverser
la planète
parce qu'en fait économiquement c'est
bizarre fille les invitations à
quelqu'un qui vient de chez paou parle
pas forcément une licence en
ang lee sang soit bilingue anglais
espagnol bon ça c'est manger écoute
vanilla allez y reste il reste est
restée reste up les y reste aux quatre
minutes allaient vanine et les voilà qui
va la gagner cela fait déjà et depuis
noël c'est gagnant lui nul soit deux
parties signent ouais ok bon il faut
serrer la vis
ok bon à certaines jouent la vie salle
geneviève lethu réseau les bas mais la
raison mais je pense que c'est même pas
certain honnêtement j'ai jamais vu van
ninh a joué pour la nul n'a aucun ne
sais pas si je sais même pas si c'est le
faire donc c'est bien lé pape outre sa
notoriété
peut-être car audio sanaa jamais tant
qu'à rallier là tu vas faire un jeu
parfois trop le ba ba hmad hammad et
trois par affaiblir un peu qu'ariel 5 la
route lille c'est sa manière à sa
manière bien et même temps d'être en
tête dans métro
non il pourrait très vite je sais pas
quelle est la station je sais que ça
marche comme ça et puis c'est la vie
mais genre prenons un autre genre le
tennis n'est pas d'un but en fait c'est
très dur de couple suspecté billets
d'avion tu payes tes coach tu étais qui
n'est dupe et au matériel
bon si tu réussis tu réussis pas et du
coup après tout joutes et tournois
locaux quand tu es locale enfin je fais
le toi tais toi dans ta région et tu vas
pas les voyages est partout après le
problème c'est qu'elle batte le modem
c'est très cher en fait dans les
tournois gens sains non mais là c'est
juste une question en voiture avec j'ai
jamais un orgue et comme toi
facile à dire d'extérieur et j'en sais
rien fait je me demande juste c'est une
vraie question bien ça se fait partout
carrément plus peut-être partie tout en
maîtrise franchement et angers 4 c'est
pas mal c'est une option at the party
arrête tour qu'il veut partir mais wall
strasse elle a vu mes gages qui
approchent cinq ans oui et qualifié ce
retour gagnant
oye mba super
franchement c'est mérité webo qui digère
transport ou jetée nice à la belote les
échecs à l'atria plomb mais ça existe
déjà en fait le tennis et chaque fois ça
existe vaguement il ya un tournant en
allemagne à chaque année j'ai jamais
fait mais la beauté chaude lors j'ai
tout ça on faisait chacun
bon celle-là se passe assez mal pour
vanina mais on s'en fout
je crois que l'endive est entre ses
mains j'ai passé les joueuses savent eux
dans sa liste je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
le temps de regarder le teint c'est
mieux de ne pas trop pour souci tout à
parti si tu joues bien tu gagnes non
mais je crains tu as moins en moins et
un sur deux quoi bon revenir à gagner
c'est ça et peut-être ya des vrais de
force à cavalia 2 au début non mais si
on peut faire du foot français 5 je
pensais à ça si mais là comme ça - mais
savoir quand elle a réagit pas mal de la
pression c'est bien joué les gars doit
toujours faible tu peux remettre un
câlin et fuite et réussissent un jour et
mais du coup tu presses des quatre
offrir un f6 fatah un plan très facile
en train de faire mais c'est sûr
qu'après a lâché que ça se vend moins
niveau visuel assez clair hop
ouais c'est le problème de trouver des
noms mais oui
visuellement bas fait ce truc c'est un
jeu vrais jeux sport comme on veut de
d'initiés dire que même si t'as jamais
joué au foot tu regardes tu vois ce qui
se passe quoi enfin parle du foot c'est
au hasard
l échec en fait c'est juste des gens qui
peut jeter plus de bois et tu comprends
pas et même quand on sait jouer c'est
pas clair de comprendre quand en plus
c'est clair donc c'est problématique
le format souvent il est
incompréhensible quoi c'est chaud c'est
bien quand les formes à élimination
directe tu vois tu as un tableau tu as
un truc c'est facile à suivre là on fait
un truc très spécial et ancian tête
dedans et c'est très conservateur parce
que vu quelque chose comme ça on
continue mais là c'est parce qu'elle
prenne armés c'est peut-être possible
d'en trouver des trucs à faire mais
évidemment faut pas non plus prendre
pour ce qu'on n'est pas
ce sera sûrement jamais le foot ou quoi
mais je pense qu'il ya moyen terme
d'avancé voilà un gros boum des échecs
au niveau des dix parrains peuvent pas
se croire trop petit coin ça ça marche
pas si mal avec plein de fautes de
français
mais pourquoi forcément copier non plus
le foot 7 foot puis voilà moitié si le
tennis mais on peut prendre des idées
qui marche ailleurs des formats des
trucs comme ça j'ai un bon général à
tour assassiné dimanche nous c'est pas
toi te défendre c'est une mare dit c'est
pas ça normalement tu te finir par un
climax et j'en envie de regarder une
finale n'est pas mal de joueurs
connectés de public spectateur que l'on
dira il attire et ça donne quoi c'est
toi et ta fille 3 monde avant la fin
puis ç'a pris trop d'avancé
il ya donc fort à ferment les open où
tout le monde fait nul pour finir pour
assurer la place mais dans une formule
parce que j'avais gagné mon prix que je
me suis battue une semaine pour la voir
le beau jeu et puis bon trouve et
organise enfin c'est du coup faut
trouver des trucs ou c'est pas possible
[Musique]
du coup c'est fini le poids d'un brownie
la lcf se venger mais en fait j'ai
appris que ouais elle a été un peu au
dessus mais s'est accroché accroché
accroché par portion boulettes et
c'était quand même le rouleau
compresseur bonne image en pensant à
jouer et je vais vite
bon à la même table pendant la foire
partie d'un quant à la saga était noir
étoilé nul n'avait peut-être ouais
j'suis d'accord on avait déjà un point
d'avancé à ce moment là donc
donc voilà du coup bon c'est une
prochaine ça repart sur une autre
session vincent porret bagnols faut les
deux pour la belle et non normalement et
joue plus la semaine prochaine
elle se reposer je ne sais pas qui joue
la semaine prochaine mais ça c'est ça
c'est tout les tous les gens qui a
qualifié donc ça c'était le deuxième
grand prix il ya cinq grands prix en
tout donc la semaine prochaine je sais
pas je ne sais pas quels sont les
joueuses qui vont jouer mais il y aura
pas eu à me vanina new chine et d'inde
encore trop forte
vient la barre ton fils un peu normal
juste pour son pseudo vanina je pense à
cause des français il ya un côté et
logique parce que valentina ait djoudi
n'a suivi ta mixte de vanina à cause de
la fonte des wallons donc si les
français qui ont baptisé comme sardinade
et ça a dû lui plaire elle a gardé la 10
e do what a cassé c'était super sympa
le match était bien foutu après j'espère
que c'était cool pour vous aussi
puis du coup mon sens soissons prochaine
compter deux trois trucs aussi encore
ailleurs pas valable mais bon y aura
d'autres joueuses de total en bonbons
merci à tous d'avoir regardé puis puis
voilà tel est le prochain
le prochain grand prix c'est kevin qui
va commenter non serait là le 10 juillet
et le 12 juillet je crois cette fois
c'est roger dimanche prochain c'est
possible bon alors 9,5 et ouais 5 et 7
ou 9 dimanche prochain donc le contrat
pour le théâtre la prochaine finale en
choeur ouais ouais c'était vraiment
sympa merci à tous d'avoir suivi puis
bientôt